Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Ich glaube, wir müssen doch noch nach Sylt.
Ja, stimmt, wir müssen einen Soli Crepe essen gegen die Punks.
Netzpolitik Nummer 4hundertunddreiunddreißig findet sich zusammen am siebenundzwanzigsten Juni zwanzig zweiundzwanzig jetzt habe ich's schon wieder gemacht.
Zwanzig zweiundzwanzig gesagt. Ja. Da weiß doch keiner, was gemeint ist. So wieder so ein Nerdcode.
Wir sagen das äh deshalb, ganz klar. Also wir fangen jetzt an, das sozusagen,
Wir freuen uns auf das Jahr zweitausenddreihundertzweiundvierzig, weil dann können wir endlich ein Jahr lang sagen, dreiundzwanzig, zweiundvierzig. Deswegen machen wir das so und nicht anders.
Dramatische Szenen in Sylt auf Sylt.
Ja.
Das ist äh.
Brunnen.
Ja, jetzt nicht mehr, jetzt ah doch immer noch, ne? Der beim Bauzaun, der hat nicht geholfen.
Und jetzt kommen Sie aus wir wir müssen jetzt einen Soli Crepe essen, weil die Sylt Urlauber trauen sich nicht mehr an den Krebsstand.
Du, man muss auch ein bisschen Empathie zeigen da für die Südurlauber, nicht wahr? Das ist für die,
weiß ich nicht, die sind da wahrscheinlich immer, die kennen's auch nicht anders und ihre Welt bricht zusammen, weil jetzt auf einmal so Punks rumlungern und das Gleiche machen, was ja auch hier in Berlin machen.
Genau, das sieht aus wie in Berlin.
Das ist für die wahrscheinlich das Schlimmste.
Es ist hart. Ja.
Das auch teilweise nachvollziehen.
Ja, es hätte auch lieber ein paar Sylt Urlauber vor der Haustür als als die Punks, aber,
sind hier gerade nicht da, insofern ich persönlich kann sagen, ich bin mit der Situation erstmal zufrieden.
Die stinkt's nicht mehr so im Hauseingang.
Riecht jetzt halt mehr nach Crémant.
Alle auf Sylt. Ja. Was ist ein Schaden, nicht? Ist das alles gleicht sich alles irgendwie immer wieder aus? Es ist so die die Gerechtigkeit, die äh kommt dann am Ende dann doch immer wieder.
Insofern halt durch. Irgendwann ist der Sommer ja auch vorbei. Dann sind die Punks auch wieder weg.
Die Urlauber auch, aber.
Ja na ja gut aber ich meine mit dem 9 Euro Ticket können ja auch irgendwo hinfahren.
Kommt nach Berlin. Wir haben hier keine Punks. Komm nach.
Ja. Gibt's auch Crepe?
Alles, also heißt halt hier irgendwie dann bisschen komplizierter, ist vegan und.
Mhm. Ist vegan und Galopp.
Mit äh ist ein Bulgur veganer veganer Bulgur Crepe oder so.
Gerade gelernt, das kommt aus der Bretagne.
Das Rad kommt aus der Bretagne.
Das gibt's dann als und als Galopp.
Das Galotte ist glaube ich das, was äh herzhafte Variante, genau.
Die herzhafte Variante. Genau. So wie dieser Podcast ist auch äh euer herzhafter Polit-Podcast. Ne? Gut gewürzt. Ja.
Und auf jeden Fall am Ende noch ein Abseckerchen.
Mit überraschenden Zutaten auch manchmal,
manchmal auch was Süßes. Aber dann heißt es ja Crpe. Ja was haben wir denn diese Woche? Du warst ganz viel im Fernsehen, davon müssen wir aber.
Erst einmal glaube ich Feedback, oder?
Ja, natürlich klar, immer.
Wir hatten äh uns in der in der letzten Sendung die Tim und ich gemeinsam gemacht haben, die ist jetzt ja schon ungefähr drei Wochen her. Da hatten wir über Trust Pit gesprochen und ein bisschen ähm,
ja überlegt, wie denn diese ähm wie das denn funktionieren kann. Da hatten wir ein bisschen Kommentare zu, die ähm,
bisschen erklären, wie das wahrscheinlich umgesetzt wird, weil wie gesagt, man findet ja keine findet alle möglichen White Paper, in denen das äh aber nicht beschrieben ist, was sie da genau machen, sondern nur, was sie vorgeben zu können, ein bisschen so wie Kryptowhite Paper.
Ich habe letztens äh mich mit einer spezifischen Blockchain Implementierung von Proof of State auseinandergesetzt,
Da steht alles feinstens drin beschrieben, was die alles können und wie toll das ist, ne? Aber einfach mal der Proof of Stake Algorithmus, den suchst du da Vergebens.
War einfach nicht erklärt. Weiß ich, also wäre jetzt der Teil gewesen, der diese Blockchain ausmacht, der interessant ist.
Ja, ist ja auch das, was man von so einem White Paper erwarten würde.
Ja, aber das musst du einfach ein bisschen innovativer sehen jetzt. Das sind ja alte, die sind ja bürgerliche Kategorien, zu erklären, wie man det Problem löst.
Aber was stand denn dann sonst da drin?
Ja, nicht das, was ich erwartet habe.
Ja gut, aber was?
Viel Singsang über äh wie gut das alles funktioniert.
Mhm. Okay, also so wie Parteiprogramm sozusagen.
War das in dem ja genau.
Bloß nicht so konkret werden, aber es wird alles schön. Wird alles super. Mhm.
Aber wird alles super und die Armen werden reich und die Reichen bleiben reich und die Wiesen werden grün und die Landschaften werden blühen und ähm genau, alles innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre.
Genau, Trust Pit. Ähm Andreas hat kommentiert, es gibt da ein altes Protokoll namens Ident.
Mit dem ein Server den kleinen fragen kann, welcher seiner User eine bestimmte TCP-Verbindung aufgebaut hat. Also du sagst ja prizipierst die IP und der Soursport,
Sag doch mal bitte, wer das jetzt war. Jetzt sagt der Andreas, etwas drumrum verhandeln oder aufbauen und wenn Spiegel DE dann eine Anfrage aus dem Telekom-Netz bekommt,
fragt, in dem Fall das das Werbenetzwerk, bei der Adresse zurück,
wer gerade von Port X Y Z gekommen ist, kriegt ihr eine Antwort. Also könnte äh gut,
Könnte so so ungefähr haben wir es uns ja auch vorgestellt im weitesten Sinne, wussten aber nicht, dass es da tatsächlich schon einen Standard gibt.
Und auch sagte, ich denke, da steckt keine komplizierte Magic hinter das wird im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich so laufen, dass der Werbeanbieter deine aktuellen IP und in dem Fall dann eben den Soursport, weil die Natten über eine API-Schnittstelle der Telekom schickt,
Telekom schaut da nach und gibt dir was zurück. Ja ähm tolle Idee. Ähm,
Dann hatten wir über die Cell Broadcast Probleme in Deutschland gesprochen,
Ich habe ja gesagt, na ja, da gibt's doch Standards für und ich kann mir einfach irgendwie nicht ganz,
vorstellen, äh dass das dass es jetzt zu Problemen führt. Und da kommentiert Dennis,
Schaut mal hier im letzten Absatz. Deutschland geht mal wieder einen Sonderweg und will vierstellige statt dreistellige Broadcast-IDs.
Daher gibt es dann die eingeschränkte Gerätebasis.
Bei solchen Protokollen, grade im Mobilfunknetz, tatsächlich Problem. Da kommen die nicht so einfach mit um. Wenn du jetzt einen ID-Range änderst, weil das eben gerne auf unterster Ebene,
sehr stark spezifizierte Protokolle sind, ne, die sich an also sehr genau daran halten, wie groß ein Feld ist,
Wenn da also jetzt jemand einen neueren Standard nimmt und sagt, uh, jetzt haben wir nicht mehr dreistellige IDs, sondern vierstellige. Dann klar kann das sein, dass ältere Geräte sagen, da kommen wir nicht mit zurecht.
Also ältere,
Infrastruktur, aus dem Mobilfunksystem, die da aus zahlreichen, von zahlreichen Providern zusammengekauft, also Herstellern zusammen also in Deutschland sind's nicht so viele, also
also Erikson wahrscheinlich Siemens ein bisschen und dieses und jenes und äh Chinesen haben sie alle rausgeschmissen, ne?
Ja, also hier Thomas Kuhn von der Wirtschaftswoche hat das tatsächlich auf Twitter veröffentlicht, die Computerbild zitiert das. Auf Twitter schreibt er, dass die meisten Handys nur dreistellige äh Side Broadcast Message IDs verarbeiten können. Damit hast du halt neunhundertneunundneunzig. Deutschland plant hier noch mit vierstelligen,
Dabei soll es sich nicht um die einzige Besonderheit handelt, warum Deutschland einfach nicht die bestehenden und gut erprobten Modelle aus anderen europäischen Ländern übernimmt ist,
Schleierhaft. Ja klar, das ist äh in der Regel äh schleierhaft, aber äh das ist würde ich sagen ein ganz klassischer Fall von,
NIHS, dem Notinventear Synchron,
Lukas sagte dann noch, als niederländischer Grenzgänger, der seine Geräte bisher ausschließlich in Deutschland gekauft hat, kann ich bestätigen, dass die Sale Broadcast-Meldungen der Niederländer sowohl auf iPhone als auch auf älteren Android-Geräten tadellos funktionieren,
Sollte Deutschland nicht wieder irgendeinen Murks machen und sich einen Standard halten, sehe ich nicht, weshalb es bei der Einführung zu Problemen kommen sollte.
Aber eben unter der Annahme, dass Deutschland keinen Wurm macht,
was eben sich mal hier wieder als die nicht korrekte Annahme erwiesen hat.
Mal gucken, ob das für dich so kommt. Also, ich meine jetzt,
auf auf einen Standard zu setzen, der jetzt erst mit Betriebssystemen für Smartphones, die in diesem Jahr rauskommen zu setzen äh.
Ohne App machen.
Dann kannst du auch sein lassen. Also ich
weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, wo da die Limitierung bei drei Stellen äh ist. Äh ich meine, was was kodieren denn diese IDs, die die Art der Warnung? Wie viele unterschiedliche Arten von Warnungen wollen sie denn da äh machen, nachdem sie noch nicht mal eine rübergebracht haben bisher?
Zum Heulen, denn dann hatte ich äh als wir über Verordnungen und Richtlinien sprachen,
Gesagt, dass sie in der Regel ein äh eine Harmonisierung des Marktes dahingehend sagen, dass ein Bereich,
Definiert wird der zu Regeln ist und ich habe in einem Nebensatz gesagt, dass jetzt auch eine Übererfüllung üblicherweise verhindert wird werden soll dadurch.
Also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise eine.
Du sprichst jetzt von der EU.
Wenn jetzt also eine Richtlinie hättest, die sagt, ein Gesetz muss kommen,
oder auch eine Verordnung, die sagt, so exakt ist es dann war meine Behauptung,
Eine Übererfüllung, also zu sagen, wir speichern nicht wie in der Richtlinie steht drei Monate, sondern sechs würde auch,
quasi im Rahmen der Harmonisierung verhindert. Da korrigiert mich Roman und sagt du sparst von einer verbotenen Übererfüllung. Das ist,
nicht korrekt, dass EU Sekundärrecht will regelmäßig,
Mindeststandard setzen, der nicht unterschritten soll,
schärfere Regelungen im nationalen Recht sind aber durchaus möglich. Er nennt dann auch noch,
paar Beispiele dafür, wo es also auch im fernen Absatzgesetz zum Beispiel der deutsche Gesetzgeber über die Vorgaben der Richtlinie hinausgegangen wäre oder wollte und das wäre auch zulässig gewesen,
Und es gibt äh also quasi äh relativ normal, dass nicht die Reichweite der Umsetzung begrenzt wird, sondern nur ein Mindestmaß der Umsetzung definiert wird. Also da habe ich was Falsches gesagt.
Man darf übererfüllen, man darf noch äh alles noch strenger machen.
Genau, harmonisiert wird der Mindestanspruch, damit wegen wenigstens die Basel äh EU harmonisiert ist, aber nicht eine Übererfüllung. Und leuchtet auch ein,
Im Sinne eines äh ewig wachsenden Überwachungsstaates äh das so machen würde.
So und dann müsst ihr mal wieder rumgereicht worden und musstest dich schminken lassen.
Ja, ich war bei Markus Lanz,
Nach längerer Zeit mal wieder. Letztes Mal war ich da zur.
Wie lange ist das schon her.
Corona-Warn-App, da war ich zwanzig, ja, irgendwann 2020 war ich das letzte Mal,
und ähm ja mhm die Bilanzeinladungen kommen ja immer sehr kurzfristig und da muss man seine Tage oder Reisen umbuchen, um dann noch hinzukommen. Äh auf auf verschiedene Weisen eine äh etwas besondere Sendung, weil.
Wo wird das aufgenommen.
In Hamburg. Wir haben so ein Studio in Hamburg,
Nähe vom Bahnhof Altona, ist das,
ähm genau, da wurde ich wurde ich eingeladen und es sollte gehen, einmal so generell um Cyberwall,
und um Chatkontrolle und da habe ich gedacht, okay, wer ist denn sonst noch so eingeladen,
Nancy Phaser Innenministerin? Ähm Julia von Weiler von Innocence in Danger,
und Daniel Bröcker, der ähm einigen vielleicht bekannt ist, der hat eine Zeit lang auch einen Podcast gemacht, den ich eigentlich auch ganz gerne gehört habe, äh,
Und Herr Brücker, Rheinische Post, die war der Chefredakteur der Rheinischen Post, ist also mit Sitze in Düsseldorf eine oberregionale Tageszeitung im im ja im Rheinland Ruhrgebiet und so,
ähm nicht die nicht die kleinste, aber auch nicht die größte überregionale Tageszeitung. Oder vielleicht ist es sogar die größte.
Mit Daniel Fine.
Hatte der im Podcast, aber jetzt ist er da inzwischen nicht mehr, der ist bei ähm irgend so einem Ding von Gabor Steingard jetzt?
Ja und er hat da seine Heimat gefunden. So die ähm.
Der war auch da. Das müsste es dann auch gewesen sein, ich der, genau, dann waren wir zu viert,
Ja sagen wir mal so, wenn du wenn du eingeladen wirst, um mit äh einer Vertreterin von Innocence in Danger äh zu diskutieren, dann weißt du eigentlich spätestens seit den,
Stoppschilddebatten. Ähm da ist Innocents and Danger erstmalig in Erscheinung getreten. Äh das sagen wir mal, dass äh dass du dich auf,
Auf einer ähm Hardliner Position einrichten muss bei der Diskussionspartnerin. Ähm,
Danger ist ein,
Verein der wenn man da die Wikipedia Seite zu liest ähm gibt es da durchaus auch Kritik an dem Laden ähm weil er eben primär durch politische Positionierung und Lobbyarbeit äh,
auffällt und nicht ganz so viel ähm tatsächliche äh Schutzarbeit,
Vorweisen kann, äh eher forschend vielleicht in dem Bereich tätig ist und,
die Vertreterin, die da war. Es hat auch mal äh,
etwas Reichweite dadurch erlangt, dass sie gefordert hat, Kinder unter 14 sollten Internetverbot bekommen.
Das heißt, da muss man jetzt, sage ich mal, schon mit mit äh drastischeren,
Positionen rechnen, insofern äh habe ich dann auf der Zugfahrt auch ein bisschen meditiert, weil ich eben wusste, okay hier wird dann äh sehr äh radikal äh vorgetragen werden.
Dann meditierst du. Wie sieht das aus.
Na ja, also du musst halt also es war meine Erwartung,
Dass die Frau Weiler jemandem in der Sendung und der beste geeignete Kandidat wäre, wahrscheinlich ich,
Täterschutz vorwerfen würde, ne? Das ist ja die ähm das ist ja klares,
naheliegendes Argument, wenn du in diesem Bereich argumentierst, ne, dass dann, wenn du jetzt sagst, ja wir möchten gerne ähm hier vielleicht nicht eine volle Überwachung der Gesellschaft haben, dass das ja dann den Tätern hilft,
dass du den den Datenschutz über den Kinderschutz stellst,
Beide Argumente wurden auch vorgetragen, Datenschutz über Kinderschutz von dem Herrn Bröcker.
Und den Täterschutzvorwurf hat aber dann die Frau Weiler Frau von Weiler am Ende der Nancy Phaser gemacht.
Ja äh insofern lief das am am Ende ganz gut. Es war sage ich mal,
leider äh ist in diesem Themenbereich oder ich war war, glaube ich, sehr froh, dass ich eingeladen war in der Sendung und vielleicht ein bisschen technische Hintergründe geben konnte, was geht und was nicht,
Erstaunlich zufrieden, weil diese Sendung, ich glaube wenn man sich die anschaut und wenn man ein bisschen äh eben guckt, was das eigentlich für ein Setup ist,
Hätte, war eigentlich sehr gut geeignet, mich da vor versammelter Mannschaft ans Kreuz zu nageln. Das hat halt, glaube ich, aus,
zwei Gründen äh sich so nicht ausgespielt. Das eine ist, dass der Markus Lanz eben durchaus äh ja,
wenn starke Überwachungsmethoden gefordert werden, die auch selber kritisch sieht und entsprechend sich auch,
detailliert damit auseinandergesetzt hat, was eben sehr nett war.
Ähm ja und das äh das andere ist, dass sie dann eben die Nancy Phaser angemacht haben. Ähm,
Also es ist glaube ich ganz gut gelaufen und wer ja wer wenn man das mal unter dem Vorzeichen schaut, wie schief die hätte gehen können, für mich die Sendung. Kann man, glaube ich, verstehen, dass ich da sehr zufrieden rausgekommen bin.
Ich habe gerade etwas verwirrt, ob das Namens, weil hier ist das so von Weiler gesagt und dann habe ich Zuweiler gelesen und tatsächlich heißt die Dame offensichtlich Julia Freifrau von und Zuweiler.
Nur eine von denen, die da äh bei äh aktiv sind, komplizierten Namen haben. Wahrscheinlich auch, nämlich.
Dass die Gründerinnen, nämlich die gute Frau von uns zu Gutenberg.
Stefanie, Anna Charlotte, Bohlfreie Frau von und zu Gutmerk.
Ja die ähm also diese schau mal aufs Gründungsdatum.
Aber was heißt denn das eigentlich von unzu? Es.
Irgendwas mit Adel, das das ist statt Doktor Titel angeboren. Äh guck mal bitte kurz, also ohne Leistung. Und schau mal kurz, ob die ähm ob wann das Gründungsdatum von Innocense in Danger ist. Es müsste irgendwo zwanzig 10, elf.
Das muss kurz vor dieser ganzen Zensursuda-Geschichte gewesen sein, oder?
Ja ja, das war nämlich plötzlich dann da.
Zwar auf einmal da. Ähm ja, nee, tatsächlich ist es schon ein bisschen älter. Also während einer UNESCO-Presse äh Konferenz Paris schloss sich 1999 eine Gruppe,
Zusammen, die sich 200 als international ausgerichtete Organisation gründete, die Aktivitäten erfolgen über nationale Vereine in der Schweiz, Deutschland, Kolumbien, Frankreich, UK und USA. Mhm, mit anderen Worten,
Dass die deutsche äh Niederlassung später kam,
2tausendunddrei,
genau.
Ja, okay, also man kann sich über den Verein informieren,
Ist auch egal, am Ende zählen die vorgetragenen Argumente und äh ja die wurden vorgetragen und der äh der Vorwurf ähm,
Angriff auf der Vorwurf des Täterschutzes fiel eben auch und ähm ja ansonsten wird das, es sind die sehr äh,
Soll man das sagen? Eben sehr sehr dramatisch. Ähm,
unterwegs. Es gab dann noch im im weiteren Gespräch äh so eine,
Und so eine Diskussion, dass wir nach der Sendung, wo dann äh vertreten wurde, es würden in Deutschland jährlich eine Millionen Kinder missbraucht.
Was das mit dem Von und zu äh auf sich hat.
Äh vielleicht kann ich das ganz kurz äh von und zu ist irgendeine Adelsgeschichte. Ist ja völlig unerheblich.
Ja ja, also von ist sozusagen der Geschlechtsname und zu ist äh der Wohnort und wenn man von unzu das gleiche ist, dann ist man.
Hast du ganz großen ganz großen Horizont.
Im Mittelalter an seinem seinem Stammsitz sozusagen überhaupt nicht weggekommen.
Okay. Wenn sie also es gab dann im Wahlkampfgespräch noch so eine so eine Zahl, die da zitiert wurde, es werden also jährlich eine Millionen Kinder, die in Deutschland missbraucht werden,
Dann habe ich mal nach dem Altersrange gefragt, ähm das werden also zwischen 0 und 13 Jahren und dann habe ich einfach gedacht, naja okay, wenn jedes Jahr eine Millionen Kinder missbraucht werden, ne, dann müssten's ja nach äh,
eben wenn wir diesen Age-Range von null bis ähdreizehn nehmen, dann müsste es ja 13 Millionen der unter 14-jährigen Kinder und Jugendlichen in Deutschland jetzt sein,
Deutschland gibt's aber nur zehn Millionen unter vierzehn,
Ja, also das heißt, wenn du davon ausgehst, dass in Deutschland eine Million Kinder,
missbraucht würden, dann wären die eben nach zehn Jahren hättest du alle Kinder durch. Insofern kann die Zahl ja jetzt nicht so ganz stimmen.
Kommen wir auch mal wieder neue dazu. Was das jetzt mit reingerechnet?
Wäre ja egal, kannst du ja in beliebigen Range nehmen. Die also es kommen neue dazu, aber die werden ja also erstaunlicherweise Tim, auch wenn du als Vater das jetzt vielleicht dir gar nicht vorstellen kannst, aber irgendwann wachsen die ja auch wieder raus. Ja.
Was? Dass das irgendwann vorbei sagst du?
Na ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall nur zehn Millionen und wenn jährlich eine Million äh dann würden halt sehr wenige äh überhaupt äh das 3zehnte Lebensjahr erreichen ohne missbraucht zu werden und ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt der Fall,
Na ja, äh ansonsten Sendung ganz gut gelaufen, glaube ich und kann man sich mal anschauen. Ich fand's äh fand's ganz nett. Wir haben dann sowas auch über Cyberwall gesprochen.
Ähm da habe ich auch äh kürzlich einen Vortrag zu gehalten, weil werde ich relativ viel zu gefragt auf Presse und so.
Und da ist mir eigentlich mal in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen was aufgefallen. Wir alle machen jetzt irgendwie ein Denken auf Cyberwall und hast du nicht gesehen, jetzt greifen die unsere kritische Infrastruktur an,
Oder jetzt gibt der Russe hat uns hat einen Port-Scan bei uns gemacht, jetzt,
Cyber War los ja und ich hatte hier schon mal in der Sendung erzählt, dass das so eben nicht funktioniert, ne, läuft bei uns ja unter Heckback-Rakete, war die Sendung, glaube ich, wo ich da relativ viel drüber erzählt habe. Was aber eigentlich die ganze Zeit keine Sau interessiert,
ist, dass wir mit den Wear-Attacken natürlich die ganze Zeit Angriffe nicht auf kritische Infrastrukturen, sondern auf die Wirtschaft des Landes haben.
Und dieser Teil, der guckt seit Jahren keiner hin,
Ja und das sind ja genau aus Russland kommende kriminelle Gruppen, der ja schon viele Vorträge hier in der Hecken habe ich das ja auch nochmal mit hier mit durchgespielt und so, wo die auch spezifisch russische äh russische Staatsbürger ausnehmen von den,
Strafzahlungen, äh was aber der Grund ist, nicht der Grund ist, dass das Patrioten sind, wie viele Leute äh behaupten, sondern dass sie natürlich einfach keine nicht der russischen,
Strafverfolgung anheimfallen wollen. Ja, also wenn du russische Unternehmen heckst, dann interessiert sich die russische Polizei für dich,
wenn du außerhalb von Russland-Leute hackst, interessiert sich russische Polizei nicht für dich. Wenn du in Russland wohnst, ist es gut, wenn die russische Polizei sich nicht für dich interessiert,
Also äh kümmerst du dich um Export.
Und ähm na ja, da habe ich also ein bisschen mal darüber gesprochen, dass in Wirklichkeit, also wenn nun alle in heller Panik sind und sagen, oh mein Gott, der Russe hackt uns jetzt wegen Krieg,
Frage ich mich, warum die letzten sieben Jahre sich nicht darüber Gedanken gemacht haben, dass jeden Tag Unternehmen gehackt werden, alles lahmgelegt wird und wir wissen längst, wie sie es tun,
Die Annahme, dass jetzt staatliche russische Hacker anders vorgehen würden, die ist ja totaler Unsinn. Mit anderen Worten, wir wissen seit 7 Jahren, wie wir unsere Unternehmen schützen müssen,
tun es nündig.
Unternehmen tun's halt auch selber teilweise noch nicht.
Korrekt ja die Unternehmen tun's selber nicht, weil's ist natürlich genau der richtige Punkt ähm kannst jetzt nicht dem Staat äh dem Staat zu verordnen, dass die Unternehmen jetzt Wiederherstellungs äh Wiederanlaufkonzepte und Backups haben sollen, das werden die schon selber müssen.
Aber es ist durchaus Aufgabe des Staates, finde ich oder zumindest, sagen wir mal, so der mentalen Führung den Kanzlerschaften und so weiter.
Wirtschaft auch mal klar zu machen was so als ist und ich glaube es hat nicht unbedingt geholfen diese permanente Rhetorik,
na ja, Neuland, Zukunft und so weiter. Das gucken wir uns irgendwann mal an, hm, nicht so wichtig und so. Ich meine, das ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer so direkt gesagt worden, aber unterschwellig war's ja immer das, ne.
Ne? Gerne gerne gerne wenn's irgendwie Innovation ist und so und Blockchain und äh blühende Landschaften und so weiter, da muss dann natürlich unbedingt reagiert werden. Aber so einfach erstmal so die Grundnotwendigkeit, mal klar anzuerkennen.
Äh haben sich doch alle sehr schwer getan und ähm ich habe so langsam den Eindruck, dass das jetzt äh
ein Ende findet, aber es hat echt lange gedauert.
Übrigens auch die ähm also hier nehmen wir ein Beispiel, Meldung vom dreiundzwanzigsten Sechsten, vier Tage her, ja? Das kannst du inzwischen von einer KI schreiben lassen. BSI-Chef warnt vor Hackerangriffen in Deutschland.
Eine zentralgesteuerte Kampagne sei im Kontext des Krieges in der Ukraine zwar nicht zu erkennen, also ich erkenne nix,
Dennoch verschärft sich die Bedrohungslage, fürchtet,
Cyber äh Sicherheitsbehördenchef,
Arne Schönbohm. Nach dem Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine hat sich die Bedrohung durch Cyberangriffe weiter verschärft,
Bereits in im Herbst hatte man in Teilen alle Alarmstufe rot ausrufen müssen. Äh lalala, eine erhöhte abstrakte Gefährdung gibt's nämlich.
Und äh dann sprechen sie irgendwie über das das äh Systeme von Rosneft Deutschland äh äh gehackt wurden und die Täter werden immer professioneller. Ende der Meldung.
Was fehlt?
Wie sollen sich Unternehmen schützen? Womit ist zu rechnen? Ne, im ersten Satz steht schon, es gibt keine Anzeichen, dass irgendwas passiert.
Aber man könnte ja mal überlegen, ähm hier sind die fünf Sachen,
die wir gerne nahelegen würden, über das sich das Level das C-Level der Geschäftsführer der Mittelständler, wer auch immer Gedanken macht. Zum Beispiel,
Mach mal einen Backup. Also ich meine, das wäre so etwas, wo ein,
für die IT-Sicherheit verantwortlicher und Verbraucherschutz verantwortlicher Mensch jetzt hier mal eine Aussage geben könnte, ne? Das Bundesamt für äh Bevölkerungs und Katastrophenschutz sagt ja auch.
Fünf Kilo Nüsse im Keller, aufpassen, dass ihr Eichhörnchen nicht klauen, 1 Liter Wasser,
diese, so viel wir euch leisten könnt. So, ne, das das sind ja die die geben einem ja Vorgaben. Aber hier hast du einfach nur äh Cyber Cyber. Ja und dann sitzen alle da und sind natürlich uninformiert und dann kommt eben auch die Nachfrage, ähm,
Da bin ich auch froh drüber, dass das dann eben mal jemand,
wie ich in dem in so eine Sendung kommt und ihr wenigstens mal erklären kann, ja womit was habt ihr denn zu befürchten,
gehen denn die Angreifer vor und das ist das, was mich an dieser ganzen Cyberbranche auch so dermaßen ankotzt, dass da nie einer reinkommt und sagt, pass auf, so und so gehen die vor, so und so schützt du dich am besten und das ist nicht am Ende ein Produkt.
Und es mag ja auch oft so sein, dass die Systemadministration dieser ganzen Unternehmen äh,
dieses Problem sehr wohl, schon längst erkannt haben und vielleicht versucht haben, intern auch dafür zu lobbyieren, dass da mal die entsprechenden Mittel auch äh,
gesetzt werden
so ist die Mutter, oh die Administration ist aber sowieso schon so teuer, so viel Personal und so weiter und jetzt wollen sie auch noch,
teure Backup-Systeme haben und alles umbauen und so, das kostet alles nur Geld.
Dass das hoch priorisiert wird, dass klar wird, dass das sozusagen etwas ist, was äh potenziell vielleicht den Untergang des Unternehmens verhindern kann, weil es gibt nicht so viele mittelständische Unternehmen, die sich äh es leisten können, mal eine komplette Woche,
ähm runtergefahren zu werden
Gut, das haben wir zwar jetzt während Corona durchaus auch gehabt, aber man hat ja auch gesehen, wie sehr alle politischen Bemühungen dahingehen, genau das zu verhindern und die Unternehmen am Laufen zu lassen und wenn
Alle anderen Konkurrenten halt weiterlaufen, weil ihre Rechner grade nicht äh nach einem Männchen anzeigen aufm Bildschirm. Na ja, dann,
ist die Konkurrenz halt auch schneller. Deswegen ist das einfach so etwas wie eine Feuerversicherung.
Ist auch tatsächlich etwas, was ich übe, also tatsächlich, wenn ich ähm Vorträge in diesem Bereich halte, dann gebe ich den Leuten, den Zuhörern und Zuhörerinnen einfach Hausaufgaben und dann schreiben die sich auch auf, ne? Okay, bergab, lalala, Lalala,
gehen die zu ihrem Atmen und sagen, pass mal auf, ich war in einem Vortrag. Da wurde gesagt, wir sollen diese Sachen beachten. Dann sagt der Admin, haben wir, haben wir nicht, gib mir nächste Woche Zeit, kümmere ich mich drum,
Das sind die Impulse, die äh an so einer Stelle gebraucht werden, auch, sage ich ganz ernsthaft oder ganz ehrlich, weil die Leute, die die Arbeit da machen, die wissen ja auch,
Alles in Schutt und Asche liegt, wenn wenn da einmal eine durchrasiert und hätten das gerne nicht. Wir haben nur häufig natürlich von der Priorisierung im Geschäft her
einfach nicht diese Aufgaben, insofern freuen die sich über externe Impulse und da könnte das BSI natürlich tolle,
tolle, tolle äh Standards setzen. Stattdessen sagen sie, pass bloß auf, dass ihr nachdenkt, bevor ihr den,
Anhang klickt. So ja geil.
Wahrscheinlich genauso effektiv wie wie wie dass man bevor man die E-Mail ausdruckt die Umwelt.
Ja, da muss er auch noch mal kurz nach.
Ja über die Umwelt äh nachdenken. Ich will mich noch kurz korrigieren. Ich habe eben gesagt, das ist wie die Brandversicherung.
Die richtige Formulierung. Es ist wie Brandschutz, ja? Also das Backup ist sozusagen euer Brandschutz. Schadet auch nix, auch noch eine Versicherung zu haben, die äh vielleicht weiß nicht, ob's mittlerweile Versicherungen gibt, die äh Attacken, solche Ausfälle versichern, das,
teuer sein.
Das tun äh ist übrigens gut, dass du das gerade fragst. Tun sie nicht. Es äh es wird grade es gibt gerade so eine ähm,
Ein Letter nennt sich das, wo einige Leute äh für das Verbot von äh diesen Zahlungen plädieren in Deutschland, also ähnlich wie es die USA auch haben,
Und da wird drin dargestellt, die es gäbe Versicherungen dagegen,
Das ist äh das ist in dieser außer äh ist in dieser Tiefe nicht richtig. Die üblichen Cyber-Versicherungspolizen in Deutschland,
ähm unterstützen nicht explizit die Zahlung von Lösegeldern.
Und das hat auch einen Hintergrund und dieser Hintergrund ist, dass Deutsch, dass in Deutschland Lösegeldversicherungen stark limitiert sind eingeschränkt, weil,
Man darf sie nicht bewerben und es gelten besondere ähm Schutzregeln für diejenigen, die eine solche Versicherung haben. Das ist damals von der BaFin,
eingeführt worden. Also wenn du eine Versicherung gegen Lösegeldzahlungen anbietest, darfst du die nicht bewerben. Die muss also individuell zwischen dir und der Person verhandelt werden und über diese Versicherung muss still schweigen.
Herrschen. Das Grund Nummer 1 warum Versicherungen, Cyber-Versicherungen diese Sachen nie covern, nie explizit,
Grund Nummer zwei, ein Verbot dieser Zahlungen ist unmittelbar zu erwarten beziehungsweise betrifft die Rückversicherer ohnehin schon. Also Rückversicherer in Deutschland,
die beiden großen Münchner,
Genered General Realswunce, Jenry gehört Warren Buffet, Warren Buffet lebt in den USA, Roan Buffet darf keine Lösegelder zahlen.
Bei.
Durch diese Statute, was in den USA schon gilt. Die sagen quasi, das gilt ist unter Kontrolle. Die dürfen dann auch teilweise kein Geschäft mit Meran machen, dann müssen die Rückversicherungsverträge neu ausgehandelt werden und so weiter. Dritter Grund ist,
Die Versicherungen haben auch keinen Bock, das zu zahlen,
teuer ist. Also was machen die ähm die definieren obliegenhalten, zu den obliegenhalten gehört, regelmäßiges Anfertigen von Backups.
Prüfung von Wiederanlauf, Backups getrennt aufbewahren und so weiter und das ist quasi deine vertragliche Obliegenheit, das zu tun.
Einer gewissen Größe des versicherten Risikos prüfen die Versicherer das auch. Das heißt, sie sagen, pass mal auf, äh also wenn jetzt was, was weiß ich, irgendein Nagelstudio bist und sagst, du machst regelmäßig Backups, sagen die ist in Ordnung,
Sage ich mal irgendwas Größeres, keine Ahnung, produzieren das Gewerbe oder so, paar Millionen Jahresumsatz, dann komm doch mal vorbei und sagen, zeig doch mal,
Wenn du das dann nicht vorweisen kannst, sagen sie, pass auf, wir können dich nur versichern, wenn du,
das jetzt änderst, dann kriegst du eine Gracespirit von zwei Monaten oder so in der Zeit hast du trotzdem Versicherungsschutz, musst es ändern,
Und in den ähm in den Klauseln steht dann so etwas drin wie äh im Fall von Datenverlust, Wiederherstellung zum letzten äh Wiederherstellungsfähigen Zustand.
So, in letzter wiederherstellungsfähiger Zustand verbirgt sich natürlich jetzt der Wiggle Room, dass die Versicherung im Zweifelsfall.
Einen Dienstleister hinzufügen kann, der im Rahmen seiner Bearbeitungskosten Daten wiederherstellt,
Bezahlt hat, in Wirklichkeit und denen nur ordnungsgemäße äh abzugsfähige Rechnung stellt,
Das ist richtig, aber du wirst nicht ähm in Deutschland eine rechtliche Handhabe gegenüber deiner Versicherung haben, dass sie dieses Lösegeld zahlen soll.
Es wird aus zwei Gründen,
du hast deine Obliegenheit verletzt, da sagt die Versicherung eh schon mal dein Problem, das Risiko wird gequotet und zweitens ist es eine Lösegeldzahlung, die spezifisch nicht in deinem Versicherungsvertrag drinsteht,
Dass das am Ende die gelebte Praxis ist natürlich eine andere. Da wird eine ökonomische Entscheidung getroffen,
und wenn für die Versicherungen sich rausstellt, okay, wir können entweder haben wir hier eine fette BU Betriebsunterbrechung,
Der Laden liegt die nächsten drei Monate brach und wir müssen für den Erhalt zahlen? Scheiße, dann gucken wir doch mal lieber, ob wir vielleicht,
nicht den Marek daran lassen, der erklärt hat, mit der,
mit dem äh Lösegeld immer ganz gut und dann äh ne, dann ist das geklärt, aber dass du dass du einen rechtlichen Anspruch darauf hättest, ist einfach nicht korrekt. Ja äh insofern äh das Feedback hatte ich denen auch gegeben. Das sind halt nicht den Tatsachen entsprechend.
Man sollte einfach das Backup-Thema im Prinzip genauso wirklich, ich finde den Brandschutzvergleich ganz gut.
Der ist absolut richtig.
Weil ähm da steckt auch viel viel drin, ja. Also Brandschutz erstmal generell um zu verhindern, dass so was überhaupt erstmal passiert, aber dann auch um klare Regeln zu haben, was man dann tut, um äh wenn es dann doch passiert ist
äh klarzukommen, also wie kriegen wir die Daten wieder rein? Wie gehen wir mit dem Ausfall um, dass man auch einen Notfallplan hat
machst du das Personal, ja? Was wie wie gehen wir mit unseren Kunden um? Wie äh was machen wir mit unseren Verträgen? Ja, wir haben Liefer zu sagen, Termin zu sagen, Pipapo ist ja ganz viel was da dran hängt. Dann hat man Ausfälle, Vertrags,
äh alles mögliche so und so was muss man sich halt dann,
auch mal generalstabsmäßig durchplanen und dann wie so eine gute Feuerschutzübung auch mal durchführen so, ne. Zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt, der,
Geeignet ist,
Das mag dann immer so ein bisschen vom eigenen Business abhängen manchmal äh gut, Mark Unternehmen geben, da gibt's äh da ist jeder Tag äh groß aktiv, aber,
Weihnachten sagen, aber es gibt halt einfach immer so.
Die Unternehmen, die sind ja da am meisten gearscht.
Ja, klar, natürlich. Ja ja, aber ich sage ja nur, also irgendein Zeitpunkt muss man finden und umso öfter man das macht
umso besser ist, desto kleinteiliger kann man's vielleicht auch testen, ja, dass man also regional äh also Firmen regional begrenzt sozusagen nur eine Abteilung erstmal äh wieder herstellt oder irgendwie so was, ne?
Wir zum Beispiel ähm.
Kann man, willst du noch sagen, äh weil das klingt ja für viele Leute so disruptiv, ne? Oh Gott, jetzt müssen wir irgendwie Backup einspielen und so weiter. Immer im Idealfall sind's irgendwie alle eure Rechner Schrott.
Kauft euch einfach Spare äh so 20 Systeme, ja, die sozusagen stellvertretend sind für äh
alles, was wir haben, ist kaputt. Konfisiert liegt bei der Polizei, ist eingeschraubt, irgendwie äh kriegen wir nicht mehr gebootet. Firmen wir im Arsch. Kann ja alles mögliche sein mit diesen Maschinen.
Versucht einfach sozusagen auf separaten Computern aus euren Datenbeständen ein laufendes System hinzubekommen, ja, was im Zweifelsfall dann auch in in den Live-Betrieb wieder mit eingreifen kann. Wenn das funktioniert, dann seid ihr schon wieder relativ äh safe in die Kacke, dann wirklich mal.
Man kann sich ja mal anschauen, also ich nehme mal als als Beispiel, was ich jetzt so beruflich zum Beispiel, wenn so ein Unternehmen von betroffen war.
Dann stehen da äh sehr nervöse, weinende Menschen und dann sagt man, okay Leute, was macht ihr hier? Er wird übrigens auch ähm,
Ja von vielen Vertretern in diesem Bereich, Cyber der Eindruck erweckt, es fehlen, es mangele dann unbedingt an den an den,
Und Cyber-Fachleuten. Das stimmt zwar,
aber deren Qualifikation wird da falsch erfasst. Worum es eigentlich geht ist, also kommst in irgendein Unternehmen rein. Morgens, Montagmorgens um acht. Okay Leute, was ist los? Ja, alles kaputt. Okay.
Was habt ihr denn hier? Ja wir sind ein Unternehmen, wir machen dieses und jenes. Okay. Sagt doch mal bitte, was ihr wiedert wichtigste IT-System ist,
Was ihr habt, ja alles, der Computer. Dann fängt man eben an und erkennt dann irgendwann okay, was wäre denn, was sind die Systeme, die ich wieder aufbauen muss, um überhaupt,
Das System, die Laden hier weiterlaufen zu lassen, zum Beispiel so etwas wie das Auftragsmanagement-Tool,
In dem das alles koordiniert wird oder äh zentrale Lager oder oder irgendwelche Dinge, ne, dann dann verstehst du hilfst du denen dabei zu erklären.
Was sie überhaupt machen und an welcher Stelle IT eine Rolle spielt. So und dann kannst du irgendwann erkennen, die haben dann ähm was weiß ich, fünf, sechs, von mir aus auch zwanzig, Kern Applikationen, die sie wirklich brauchen,
Ähm wenn Sie zehn davon wieder haben, können Sie schon wieder in Notbetrieb gehen, die Betriebsunterbrechung wird also äh geht zurück,
und die restliche 20 sind irgendwie, was weiß ich, regulatorische Anforderungen oder was nicht alles, ja? Und dann kannst du sagen, alles klarkommen, das machen wir als allerletztes, jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken, dass die Bude hier wieder läuft,
Kollege von mir hat kürzlich einen Vortrag über seine Erfahrung da gehalten, meinte dann irgendwie so ähm also da da war ein Fall in einem Hotel,
Und im Hotel ist natürlich zum Beispiel was, was bei denen das Problem war? Sie konnten keine Leute ein- und auschecken. Das ist scheiße. Weil der Rest von dem Hotel,
Funktioniert ja erstmal ohne IT, ja? Also wenn du erstmal in der Lage bist die Leute reinzulassen und den den die in ihr Zimmer zu lassen, dann hast du schon mal einen größeren Teil des Problems geklärt. Ja, wenn du dann der Küche sagst, heute kein Internet,
mal äh geht mal zu Aldi und seht zu, dass er hier was kocht für unsere Leute, dann hast du einen größeren Teil des Betriebs, der steht schon wieder, ja? Also der läuft schon wieder.
Diese Vorarbeit mal zu leisten. So.
Verschlimmert sich zumindest nicht mehr.
Nicht. Wenn hier alles in Schutt und Asche liegt, was brauchen wir als Erstes wieder? Und dann kannst du natürlich auch sagen, gut, dass das ähm am Laufen bleibt, da setzen wir die meiste Zeit drauf. Und dann kannst du anfangen zu sagen, okay, wir trennen in unseren Backups zum Beispiel Systemekonfigurationen und Daten.
Ja also das das Windows brauchen wir nicht zu sichern. Das gibt es im Internet.
Brauchen die spezifische Konfigurationen für den iS oder für die für die Server, ja? Und da kommt ja dann auch interessanterweise, so werden ja auch heute Server administriert, dass sie eben am Ende einen Playbook hast. Und wenn du das richtig, richtig gut raus hast,
die wenigsten haben es, ja, aber zumindest ich für meine fünf, sechs Server, ich habe meine Backups, die liegen da und am Ende ist es eigentlich immer nur die Datenbank,
Und vielleicht noch die Webapplikation, die installiert werden muss. Dafür hast du encible Playbooks und wenn der Server weg ist, dann klicke ich mir einen neuen und installiere das da drauf. Fertig ist die Laube. Stell ausm alten Backup wieder her.
Ne so aber in diesem in diesen Reifheitsgrad musst du erstmal kommen, weil IT-Sicherheit eben kein Zustand ist, sondern ein Prozess. Wir sind total abgewichen, Tim.
Ja, aber das ist es ist es ist ein schöner Exkurs und du hast gerade was echt tolles gesagt,
Du hast gesagt, man kommt da rein und dann erklärst du ihnen, was sie überhaupt machen. Das ist wirklich, also das das die Erfahrung habe ich auch äh gemacht, weil ich das erste Mal in irgendeinen Laden kam, wo irgendein Computersystem lief, dass einfach dadurch, dass die Leute,
Ihr ganzes Unternehmen und ihren ganzen Betrieb nur noch über die Bedienung von Software erleben, dass sie eigentlich teilweise einfach oder vielleicht auch vollumfänglich,
eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht mehr wissen, was so der eigentliche Modus Operandi ihres Unternehmens ist und was sind die wichtigen Prozesse und was sind die nicht so wichtigen Prozesse. Es gibt diesen,
schönen Witz, den man immer wieder einfällt so,
so auf der Straße so eine größere Menschengruppe um irgendetwas herum versammelt und alle gucken irgendwie und gehst da so hin und sagst ja ja was ist denn überhaupt passiert?
Na ja keine Ahnung der Letzte der es wusste ist vor zehn Minuten gegangen und und so
so kommen wir das sozusagen auch immer vor in diesen Unternehmen, dass sie einfach sozusagen geblendet sind äh äh nur noch von von von diesem System,
Aber wenn du sie mal fragst, so what is it? Ja, dass dass sie dann einfach,
erstmal anfangen müssen, nachzudenken und das so sich gar nicht herleiten können und das natürlich für dich eine Schwäche und das ist auch eine eine Dokumentationsschwäche quasi im Unternehmen, als soll ich mal ganz unabhängig von dem Computer, aber durch Software wird das natürlich alles noch viel komplexer.
Ich würde eine Sache ergänzen, die mir die mir an der Stelle wichtig ist so. Wir erklären es ihnen nicht, sondern wir helfen denen dabei, es uns zu erklären.
Rauszufinden sozusagen, ja.
Und und das ist eine eine Übung, die könnt ihr jeden Abend einfach machen,
Dann erkennen, wo was müssen sie schützen, was nicht. Und äh das war auch der Punkt, den ich gerade noch machen wollte. Die eigentliche Expertise,
zur Lösung des Falles, die ist schon in dem Unternehmen drin. Die brauchen gar keine äh also die bräuchten,
Keine IT-Security Consultants und Incident-Responder.
Die brauchen die aber natürlich, weil die ruhig sind, weil die ne vielleicht ein bisschen Kompetenz ausstrahlen und sagen und weil denen halt auch scheißegal ist, ja, deswegen sind die nicht so emotional.
Aber äh ne, also du brauchst sie als Krisenmanager die Erfahrung im Umgang mit solchen Situationen haben. Aber du brauchst sie nicht,
jetzt gerade irgendeine Kompetenz fehlt, die Kompetenz zur Wiederherstellung des Betriebs,
in der Regel bei den Admins, die den Laden da seit zehn Jahren regelmäßig einölen und entgegen aller Wahrscheinlichkeiten zehn Jahre am Laufen gelassen haben, bis er denn final eingekracht ist und dann redest du eben mit der
Business-Seite, denen die da wirklich das Geschäft machen, denen, die die IT machen und sagst, okay, in welcher Reihenfolge bootsrappen wir denn hier mal was Neues, damit der Laden wieder läuft? Und die Übung könnten die selber machen, wenn sie nicht so
Trump dramatisch drauf wären, ja? Das heißt, wenn du das einfach mal vorher machst, könntest du das sehr viel günstiger haben und äh äh in Ruhe klären,
Okay, viel zu lange. Wir sind immer noch bei Markus Lanz.
Immer noch? Tatsache, ne? Verlassen wir diesen Bereich doch mal und äh reden nächstes Medienengagement.
Ich bin in die Fußstapfen von Danger Dan Ronensteinke, Gerhard Baum und mein Kim getreten. Ja. Willst willst du ja wohl mal meinen ey. Da bist du platt, wa.
So ein bisschen nach einem neuen YouTube-Kanal.
Ich war eingeladen bei Freiheit Deluxe ähm ein Podcast äh um dessen Titel ich hard kneide äh mit Jakota Marinitsch, der ist ziemlich gut, höre ich ohnehin schon.
Und äh ja da äh hatte ich die große Freude,
zu Gast zu sein, habe ich auch mal verlinkt, war sehr sehr schön, so ein bisschen auf 'ne Metaperspektive zu gehen, der Podcast setzt sich eben mit äh Freiheit auseinander, ist ein Thema, für das ich mich durchaus interessiere,
und ähm natürlich auch mit den Menschen, die da zu Gast sind und äh ja, den kann ich ohnehin äh empfehlen und äh habe mich auch sehr gefreut,
da zu sein.
Bei HR2 Kultur.
Ja halt zwei Kultur, aber der ist schon eher vom vom äh Branding her sehr äh also weniger HR spezifisch als äh spezifisch ne, ist relativ klar, dass sie da die,
Die äh Hauptrolle spielt. Hm der der ist äh.
Schon immer meine Meinung, dass auch die äh öffentlichen rechtlichen Radiosender äh ihre eigene Podcastkultur entwickeln müssen. Ja. Und da gehört natürlich persönliche Prägung sehr dazu.
Genau äh.
Auf jeden Fall also online und dauert boah schneide 1hundertneun Minuten. Habe ich nicht gehört. Tja. Da du warst bestimmt sehr charmant und eloquent.
Habe ich hab's versucht. Dann war ich noch äh dann bin ich noch in die Fußstapfen von äh Luisa Neubauer und Katja Diel getreten.
Habe dich einfach das das Upcoming der Shooting Star, wie man so schön sagt auf Deutsch, auch wenn es ja eigentlich das Verglühen schon vorhersagt.
Das ist äh glaube ich bei mir schon nur noch so ein Verglühen.
Wollte ich nur gleich mal einordnen, nicht dass du da so über.
Äh ich war und zwar war ich bei äh Raul Krauthausen,
Und äh Benjamin Schwarz äh ist glaube ich der Name zu Gast. Raul Krauthausen ist ja tatsächlich auch jemand, den du hattest den schon sehr früh aufm Schirm. Du hast nämlich mal mit dem äh einen CRE gemacht, ne? Über Wheel-Map.
Ja, kenne ich schon ziemlich lange, weil er war früher bei Fritz auch.
Der war mal bei Fritz.
Also im im damals glaube ich im im Website-Team oder so, also der hat ja äh da an der in Potsdam studiert,
War ja schon immer so ein total äh,
krasser aufgeweckter Typ. Ja. So, ja, also äh natürlich seine Erscheinung, wer ihn gesehen hat so äh mit seiner Glasknochen äh Krankheit.
Mit seinem Rollstuhl gut unterwegs, aber ich kenne wenig Leute, die so viel Aktionismus ist nicht das richtige Wort, Aktivität.
Aktivität.
Aktivismus versprühen, also der ist immer so äh immer schon wieder so eine Straßenecke weiter, was man sonst noch machen könnte. Der hat so dermaßen viele,
losgetreten, Real Map bisher nur ein Beispiel, dann hier auch diese ganze äh.
Da eigentlich auch Gründer.
Ja, genau, das ist sein großes Projekt eigentlich, sozialhelden, ne, so diese ganzen Tafel, Projekte losgetreten haben. Also, es ist ein ein ganzes Universum
dann äh hat er auch noch angefangen und das Geilste war, bevor er mit diesem Podcast angefangen hat, hat er ja sogar diese Fernsehsendung gehabt und ausgerechnet,
Ich hoffe, sie sagt dir, das ist ein richtiger Kanal, aber ich glaube, da bei SPOT1. Besonderen äh Hack. Ja ja, diese Krauthausen äh Sendung.
TV, ne?
TV. Habe ich recht? Das ist doch äh bei Sport eins, ne?
Eins, ne, warte mal, mein er ist so viel Challenge Krauthausen Face to Face bei Sat. 1 Gold.
Max, mittlerweile äh gewandert sein, aber das war definitiv fing das dort an. Ich bin hier echt komplett weggeschmissen. Super. Ja und äh.
Deutscher Engagementpreis, deutscher Bürgerpreis ähm und seit 20013 Bundesverdienstkreuz am Bande. Ja also.
Ja ja. Ja und auch alles verdient. Also das äh Roll ist super und ähm.
Hat er auch,
Alles ja, Spitzentyp und genau, entsprechend habe ich mich da natürlich auch sehr gefreut, weil übrigens der der Podcast-Titel hier ähm wie kann ich was bewegen?
Ist ja auch, wenn ich das jetzt so richtig äh sehe, auch nur so einen Nachklapp vom Buch, was sie zusammengeschrieben haben.
Da fühlt man sich dann gleich schlecht immer.
Ja das ist äh genau. Wie kann ich was bewegen? Genau Benjamin Schwarz, das Buch können wir auch nochmal verlinken hier und äh ja genau, da war ich zu Gast. Das war äh etwas kürzer.
Der Podcast.
Online oder.
Der ist auch noch nicht online. Ich vermute, die sind da ähm werden da noch ein bisschen bei der der Podcast mit äh Jagoda hat auch ein bisschen gedauert, bis der dann da veröffentlicht wird. Die haben dann da Leute für und die arbeiten halt nicht so schnell wie wir.
Okay, sieht nach den zwei Wochen äh Rhythmus aus. Letzter war 21. Juni, kann also noch zwei Wochen dauern, bis er rauskommt.
Ja, aber genau, das war auch sehr nett und auch den Podcast kann man natürlich empfehlen, Raul aufm Schirm zu haben ist ohnehin nahegelegt. Ey, das war auch noch krass. Der hatte äh das ist jetzt ja kein Geheimnis, der wurde ja angefahren.
In Kreuzberg vom SUV mit seinem Rollstuhl. Ja ja.
Nein. Ach echt? Das habe ich nicht.
Hatte er auf Twitter dann auch, es war wenige Tage davor,
Und äh äh hatte dann irgendwie also er hatte so ungefähr Rollstuhl von ihm ist natürlich relativ schwer, weil er natürlich das feinste Gerät hat.
Mittlerweile, ja? Mhm.
Akku und so.
Wenn man den auf Konferenzen trifft, der hat immer einen USB-Ladefort dabei.
Ich habe ich sage mal so, ich will dem jetzt nichts unterstellen im guten Raul, ne? Aber so wie ich den manchmal durch die Gegend fahren sehe, ne?
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass der über den USB-Port auch ein paar Sachen an dem Rollstuhl noch, sage ich mal, individuell eingestellt hat. Nein, aber wirklich ein tragischer Fall, der wurde oder ein,
ein tragischer Fall mit sehr glücklichem Ausgang. Er wurde von so einem SUV aufm Bürgersteig mitgenommen, ne,
Hat sich dabei auch äh schwer verletzt, weil er jetzt ja auch äh äh die ähm ich habe jetzt leider den richtigen Namen vergessen der Krankheit.
Gasknochenkrankheit ist das.
Der ist der ja ist dieser äh äh wie nennt man das Volksmund?
Äh Osteogenes Imperfector.
Da hat er also entsprechend natürlich trotz also obwohl er zum Glück nicht überfahren wurde, sondern der Rollstuhl halt,
Die Stabilität gehalten hat und auch die kinetische Energie größtenteils aufgenommen hat, jetzt im Arsch ist. Ähm hat er sich dabei auch äh durchaus nennenswert verletzt, aber er hat dann doch den den Podcast mit mir gemacht. Es war,
sehr cool ja der hat jetzt auch die nächsten Monate Ärger, weil,
Das richtig verstanden habe, dir Podcasts, eine Lieferabhängigkeit aus der äh der Podcast. Der Rollstuhl-Lieferabhängigkeit aus der Ukraine hat.
Gott.
Kann man sich in dem Podcast anhören. Ich will ja jetzt nicht nur mir erzählen, ich will jetzt keine Rumors weiter äh bringen. Man kann sich das oft auf Twitter anschauen. Er ist ja sehr aktiv da auch und kann man auch auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
Zu folgen und ist immer interessant, was er jetzt auch nochmal wenigstens erklären sollen. Da hat er sich nämlich damit auseinandergesetzt zu Mappen, welche Stationen,
Im Berliner ÖPNV.
Nicht nur im ÖPNV, es ging generell um öffentliche Einrichtungen, Cafés, Restaurants, Zugänglichkeit, äh das heißt Remap ist einfach eine App, die du runterladen kannst und dann kannst du quasi für Orte so ein einfaches Taging machen. Wie ist die Zugänglichkeit?
Kommt man hier oben.
Die Barriere frei oder.
Guck mal hier ohne Stufe rein äh et cetera gilt das auch für die Klos et cetera PP. So ganz einfache Dinge,
für einfach wichtig sind im Vorfeld zu wissen, weil das willste ja nicht vor Ort äh rauskriegen und,
das ist halt so dieses äh ja könnte man mal gebrauchen, also machen wir das einfach mal. Später hat er dann dasselbe äh Ding dann weitergedacht für die Fahrstühle der Station, das hat du jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade.
Stimmt, da war das.
Ne
weil immer die Fahrstühle ausfallen, dann dauert's immer ewig und um das irgendwie zurückzumelden und äh zu tracken und dann auch schnell an die BVG zu melden, damit die dann auch irgendwie mal nicht erst nach Monaten
Anfang mal wieder einen Fahrschlüssel äh fixen, weil klar dauert das manchmal, nur die Aufmerksamkeit war halt in dem Sinne nicht da und das ist natürlich für Leute, die an der Stelle einfach eingeschränkt sind und von Fahrstühlen einfach
abhängen, also für die auch jetzt sagen wir mal nur eine Rolltreppe, nur eine geringfügige Verbesserung ist, weil ja dann ähm ja dann ähm so und das das,
so sehr, dass er auch super,
pragmatisch über die Sachen nachdenkt und dann aber auch in der Lage ist, in seiner Community Leute zu finden, die sagen, das machen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Ja ist ja auch nicht nicht so schwer zu mal eben zu Crowdsossen,
Musste halt mal anstoßen, ne, aber und die Menschen dazu bringen, dass sie halt einfach sagen, ach ja hier, ich bin mal wieder in einem Café, ich klicke mal eben, ob das wie das hier ist. Kostet mich eine Minute.
Dass wir eben zu klären und ja kann am Ende vielleicht einem anderen Menschen die Reise ermöglichen von drei drei Kiezen weiter mal zu sagen, ach dann trinken wir da mal einen Latte.
Willst du Crowdshausen, musst du Crowdhousen?
Jo
Äh das stimmt. Ich glaube, damit haben wir äh Raul jetzt auch ehrlich mal gefeatert.
Zeit wird's.
Und ähm genau das Buch mache ich auch noch mal gleich rein. Ähm so, dann war ich noch bei The Next Web in Amsterdam,
War lustig, weil längere Zeit nicht in Amsterdam. Habe ich da eine eine habe ich den Vortrag gehalten auf englische Sprache natürlich nach Linus Schamanier äh auf der Hinreise noch schnell die Folien geklickt.
Was ist denn das für ein Event.
Scheint so ein bisschen die Republica von Holland zu sein,
Das ist eine relativ großes Unternehmen, was irgendwann auch offenbar von der Financial Times gekauft wurde, die eine relativ große Webseite haben. Die haben einen Twitteraccount mit einer Millionen Followern,
machen da halt diese fette Konferenz einmal im Jahr und die war jetzt auch ziemlich üppig. So von der äh Ausstattung her und äh,
hatte so ein bisschen Republica, Perspektivearbeit, glaube ich, sehr viel äh Business geprägter. Ja und vor mir war äh so ein so ein Vöglein.
Der hat da irgendwas von irgendeiner,
Meterversumskarte, die er da verkaufen wollte den Leuten, da können sie nämlich jetzt Land in in seiner Welt als NFT kaufen, so ein Scheiß, ne,
und das ist alles total geil und dann haben ihn irgendwie hat ihn nachher jemand gefragt so ja äh du redest hier die ganze Zeit von Geld und Gebühren und so ne, wie soll ich denn mit meinem gekauften Land,
in deinem Internet jetzt Geld verdienen, ne? Und dann meint er so ja äh hm also ähm,
Äh du könntest ja zum Beispiel also eine eine unserer Funktionalitäten ist ja, dass man über diese Welt fliegen kann und sich die anschauen kann und dann könntest du ja für die äh äh für die Überflugrechte Geld nehmen,
damit ich von Leuten Geld kassiere, die da drüber fliegen. Also es war ein hm deswegen mache ich meine Vorträge auch immer in der letzten Minute, weil das halt einfach so solche Chance kriegst natürlich auf Silbertablett,
wissen ja auch uns allen ist ja gerade gerade der Markt für für Grundstücke ist uns ja allen sehr sympathisch,
das zeigt ja auch wie gut das so funktioniert für uns alle, ne? Da sehen wir richtig den Reichtum von unten in die Gesellschaft strömen, ja?
Also wirklich, also wenn wir hier an funktionierenden Markt denken, dann denke ich so richtig bloß so, jo Grundstücke, das ist richtig geil, ne, da wird jetzt so richtig, da wird jetzt der Web von unten für uns äh totaler. Ich hoffe mal, dass die äh dass die Aufzeichnung irgendwann befreit wird.
Ich muss mal irgendwie gucken. Also ich kriege die auf jeden Fall als Privatkopie und dann lade ich die einfach auf YouTube hoch.
Sind die denn die alten äh talksten.
Die haben irgend so eine Zweitverwertung, wenn ein Konferenzticket hast, kannst du die angucken und ansonsten sollst du Geld dafür bezahlen, um die Aufzeichnungen zu schauen.
Ich gucke gerade mal, also es gibt eine Playlist vom The Nextwep zwanzigneunzehn.
Ja okay, weil so lange würde ich jetzt nicht warten.
War dein Talk? Halbe Stunde.
Dreiviertelstunde, ich glaube halbe Stunde.
Ja, hier sind nur so 7zehn Sachen von 9zehn.
Nee, nee, nee, die haben da irgendwas. Ich muss da nochmal nachfragen. War auf jeden Fall auch sehr interessant, weil,
Also erstmal haben wir anderthalb Stunden nach dem Talk noch diskutiert, wann alle möglichen Leute mit,
eine mit unterschiedlichsten Ansichten zu NFTs, dann waren da auch irgendwie habe ich hier der britische Journalist Jeff White war da, der äh hier zu Lazarus viel gemacht hat,
ein bisschen gequatscht und äh ja, das war glaube ich ungefähr der Talk, für den ich das meiste also jemals das meiste positive Feedback hatte,
Dann ist mir aber irgendwann auch einfach klar geworden, dass, sage ich mal, Niederländer einfach ein bisschen,
Moor ein bisschen extrovertierter sind, ein bisschen freundlicher und bisschen mehr auf Leute zugehen.
Amerikanischer.
Bisschen amerikanischer im, hey, cooler Talk und so weiter. Zwischendurch habe ich echt gedacht, so boah, das kann ja gar nicht sein,
beste Talk ever. Ja das war auch ganz nett und ich ich werde mal gucken, dass ich den befreit kriege.
Du hast irgendwie gemacht, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, ich habe also ich habe mal ein bisschen ähm eben erklärt, was da,
Was da gerade passiert, ne, dass dass die gerade also Kernthese im Prinzip, ne, dass die ja immer mehr in ihre Blockchain reinzerren müssten,
dieses Pyramidenschema weiter funktioniert. Und habe dann auch am Ende nochmal meine These vertreten, die ich ja hier auch schon öfter vertreten habe. Ähm Blasen platzen erst dann,
Irgendwann letzte Woche oder so jetzt so Samstag vor einer Woche vielleicht,
also vor zehn Tagen oder so, ich weiß es nicht, bin etwas viel unterwegs gewesen, habe da ein bisschen zwischendurch die zeitliche Orientierung verloren,
ähm dass das Blasen erst dann platzen, wenn sie in der Lage sind die ganze Ökonomie in in in ab ins Abwasser zu reißen, ja? Also wenn du jetzt so eine richtig schöne Blase hast, die geht nicht zwischendurch mal kaputt,
So oh jetzt ist die Blase geplatzt, nein,
Platz dann, wenn dir deine komplette nationale Ökonomie mit in Keller reißt. Deswegen glaube ich auch nicht, dass Krypto grade der finale Pop ist. Ja, das wird da müssen noch mal eine ganze Menge mehr Idioten drauf,
das nächste Mal, wenn's hoch geht, noch mehr Risiko da reinhängen und noch mehr Scheiße dran knoten, damit wenn das Platz auch wirklich eine Wirtschaftskrise ausgelöst wird. Ähm,
Na ja, also da haben wir ein bisschen drüber gesprochen und wie gesagt, ich hoffe, dass wir den irgendwie befreit kriegen und veröffentlichen.
15. Juni war das.
15. Juni. Ja also vor vor 12 Tagen.
Ja, aber ich wollte gerade mal aufn äh Bitcoin-Kurs gucken.
Der ist am Tag danach um 10 Prozent als 20.
Ja ist äh okay, also um fair zu sein, ist es vorher schon kräftig runtergegangen, aber ist dann halt nicht besser.
Kam noch mal ein richtiger Dip von IWC Prozent oder so. Ja ja, das war ihm unmittelbarer Anschluss.
Ja. Aber okay, gut, aber fair, wir sind jetzt gerade wieder auf dem Level vom Fünfzehnten, also du hast es jetzt nicht komplett reingerissen. Na ja, da geht noch was auf jeden Fall.
So dann haben wir eine Ankündigung, äh schon von so vielen vergangenen Terminen sprechen. Haben wir auch schon angekündigt. Wollen wir jetzt nur, jetzt können wir, glaube ich, sagen, wer unsere Gäste sind auf der Fusion, ne?
Wenn es sich nicht noch kurzfristig ändert, man weiß ja nie.
Also jetzt dürfen die einfach keine Tests mehr machen,
Testverbot.
Genau, Testverbot für Katharina, die wird äh bei uns sein,
das ist die, die wir schon mal hatten.
Vor vielen Jahren.
Vor vielen Jahren, genau, aber er ist immer noch ganz frisch und ja ne,
Wissenschaftlerin, Polizistin, Netzaktivistin, alles mögliche hat sie schon gemacht, hat sich vor allem
letzten Jahren sehr viel mit Verschwörungstheorien
Fake News, Fake Facts, äh dieser ganzen Welt auseinandergesetzt und wir dachten, das ist vielleicht eine ganz gute Gelegenheit, jetzt nach gerade zwei Jahren Corona da auch noch mal so ein bisschen äh Bestandsaufnahme äh zu machen.
Und dann werden wir noch den Karl dabei haben. Kalk Engelharz, der ist äh Hacker und Promira und auch äh Aktivist, machbar fragt den Staat mit und auch bei Zerforschung hatten wir ja auch schon mal mit äh Little drüber gesprochen
ja wollen auch äh mit ihm, wie es dann so unsere Art ist, mal über seine Arbeit sprechen und äh,
Methoden Vorgehensweisen und,
Spaß haben auf der Bühne und zwar dann am zweiten Juli auf der Fusion einundzwanzig Uhr bis zweiundzwanzig Uhr dreißig. Also wer tatsächlich auf der Fusion rumhopst, ein paar Leute sind ja da. Kommt doch einfach mal rum.
Um 9 am Samstag, das ist der Fusion-Samstag, falls ihr.
Samstag um neun, um es mal einfacher zu sagen.
Samstag um neun, ne? Wenn es jetzt nicht eine Talkbühne wäre, eigentlich ein ziemlich geiler Slot. Also nächstes Mal äh reiche ich wieder eine Bewerbung als DJ ein.
Am Schluss noch eine Platte auflegen. Merkt dann keiner.
Samstag um neun bis bis ungefähr 2undzwanzig Uhrdreißig kann ein paar Minuten länger gehen können, paar Minuten kürzer gehen und äh hier die Zerforschung hat ja auch gerade wieder über die Digga die digitalen Gesundheitsapps veröffentlicht,
Kommt eben entsprechend heute bei uns kurz.
Vielleicht ein bisschen länger.
Da werden wir dann in Ruhe darüber sprechen.
Bringt doch noch irgendwie einen Plattenspieler mit, dann werfen wir zwischendurch kannst du Set. Seitenspieler. Ja.
Spieler pass auf, Plattenspieler nach nach Lehrz tragen wäre wie Eulen nach Lehrz tragen.
Ach, schöner Doppelwitz. Ja.
Ein schöner Doppelbenzert. Dann will ich bei der Gelegenheit noch kurz auf eine Petition des Fusion Festivals hinweisen. Denn äh auch das ein Thema, mit dem ich mich auseinandergesetzt habe, ähm,
Wissen ja einige, dass ich äh mit dem,
Kulturkosmos in äh immer mal wieder aktiv bin ähm im Bereich der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit und entsprechend haben wir hier auch ein bisschen drüber gesprochen damals ähm in in verschiedenen Bereichen hier auch darüber gesprochen,
weil es damals 20019 vor den ähm,
vor den vor der Pandemie ähm,
quasi ein ein Problem gab, dass mehrere Festivals betroffen hat und das betraf äh Nacktaufnahmen von Besucherinnen, die dann im Internet veröffentlicht wurden,
Es gab einmal diesen Fall, der äh das Festival Monis Rache betraf. Da waren versteckte Kameras auf den Dixies angebracht worden.
Das ist nicht dieser Fall, von dem ich jetzt spreche, sondern in einem anderen Täter,
mit einer versteckten Kamera eben der Duschbereich gefilmt wurden.
Ähm wir haben dann ähm uns mit einem Anwalt auseinandergesetzt. Wir haben über Strafanzeige tatsächlich sogar den Täter identifizieren können.
Und ähm wir haben dann, da sind wir natürlich davon ausgegangen, dass der jetzt seiner einer Strafe zugeführt wird und dann wurde aber, wurden wir darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt, dass das, was der getan hat, nicht illegal war.
Denn ähm du darfst Leute, die nackt.
Öffentlichkeit in weitesten Sinne sind, darfst du fotografieren,
und solange die nicht persönlich sich dagegen aussprechen, darfst du auch die Bilder davon veröffentlichen,
anderen Worten, du kannst, also sagen wir mal in einer Situation Sauna, in einer Situation FKK-Strand, in einer Situation öffentliche Dusche im Schwimmbad.
Darfst du hingehen, kannst diese Menschen fotografieren und kannst sie nachher als WIX-Vorlagen ins Internet stellen? Dann kann sogar die Polizei kommen und dann gehst du straffrei aus, weil du kein Gesetz gebrochen hast.
Erstaunlicher Sachverhalt, schwer vorstellbar.
Oder so. Ist aber so. Mhm.
Ist aber so. Ähm und der äh tatsächlich die Einschränkung,
äh wo das jetzt nicht mehr erlaubt wäre, wäre zum Beispiel, du bist in einem vollständig geschlossenen Raum, wie einer Toilette, also dieser Fall auf dem Festival Monis Rache, der war verboten, weil der Raum vollständig geschlossen war,
oder zum Beispiel bei dir zu Hause, ne? Wenn du in deinem eigenen Raum bist äh äh und würdest dann da gefilmt werden, auch nicht erlaubt,
Aber das heißt, hier ist quasi in diesem also du musst dich in einem Gegeneinblick besonders geschützten Raum befinden, nur dann ist es äh illegal. Also Sauna, Duschen, Schwimmbädern, Badesee
FKK-Strand, alles völlig legal, kannste nix gegen machen. Du könntest dann noch gegen die,
Verbreitung des Bildes könntest du allenfalls über das Kunsturhebergesetz vorgehen, um dann eben hier dein ähm.
Ja, dieses äh diese äh diese Recht das Recht an deiner an deinem Körper als Kunstwerk und dessen Verbreitung äh geltend zu machen?
Dann gab es diesen ähm diesen Paragraph, der dann nämlich, ich glaube Ende zwanzig neunzehn,
Nee, war das schon zwanzig. Nee, das war zwanzig 20. Wurde dieser Paragraph besprochen. Das war eine große Petition auch mit wichtigen Zielen, weil Leute untern Rock zu fotografieren, war auch nicht verboten.
Das musste dann zwanzigzwanzig ähm glaube ich war das verboten werden,
und Paragraph, der dann eben sagt, dass du,
Körperstellen also wenn du Körperstellen fotografierst, die bedeckt sind,
Dann ist es auch strafbar. Das war die Änderung vom äh durch den Ups Göttingen Paragraf, ja? So vorher durftest du Leuten auch untern Rock fotografieren, die Bilder veröffentlichen.
Seit 1. Januar einundzwanzig.
Einundzwanzig, dann war die dann war nämlich die ganze äh Situation äh zwanzig zwanzig. Da hat der Kulturkost beziehungsweise der Anwalt des Kulturkosmos,
entsprechende Sachverständigen ähm Forderung, Auskunft nochmal äh beigetragen und hat gesagt, hier wir möchten, dass bei diesem,
Also das Upskirting-Ding geht nicht weit genug, verbietet doch einfach Nacktaufnahmen ohne äh Konsens,
Und äh da wurde eben der der hundertvierundachtzig KSTGB muss eben alle unbefugten Aufnahmen des unbekleideten Intimbereichs ähm betreffen ohne irgendwelche Ausnahmen oder Spezifikationen, die dazu führen, dass andere Dinge,
nicht äh erfüllt sind. Das hat damals, da waren wir zu spät. Ja, der der die Auskunft und die Forderung haben wir erst quasi, da war schon die Ausschusssitzung,
Und dann war das Ding kurz danach im äh im äh Bundestags äh im Bundestag und dann wurde halt gesagt, nee, wir müssen das jetzt entscheiden und hier dieses das größere Problem zu lösen, das müssen wir in einem separaten,
Prozess machen, weil das Göttingen jetzt zu wichtig ist. Daran wollen wir jetzt den Justizminister Buschmann erinnern, beziehungsweise möchte der ähm,
Kulturkosmos jetzt den Justizminister erinnern und hat dazu eine Petition zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt äh knapp 10.000 Unterzeichnerinnen.
Ja da würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr euch dieser Petition auch anschließt, weil das ist ja schon wirklich faszinierend, wenn etwas, was wir alle vollständig ganz normal als Schutz für uns in Anspruch nehmen durch das Gesetz nicht sichergestellt ist.
Gut, damit haben wir aber hier unsere Kurzmeldungen durch, würde ich sagen und äh wir können uns auf die äh wichtigen Sachen konzentrieren,
was wir äh schon seit Längerem haben, links liegen lassen, ist die drohende Auslieferung von Julian Assange,
Die äh wie zu erwarten war jetzt von der britischen Regierung genehmigt wurde. Da wurde ein sogenannter Auslieferungsbefehl ausgestellt.
Wenn die USA sagen, jetzt schickt das auch mal, dann äh dann wird der.
Ernsthaft darin ausgeliefert.
Dann wird es äh definitiv stattfinden, ob die USA das jetzt auch tun wird, dass ähm kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht einschätzen. Immerhin haben wir jetzt eine andere Regierung, aber ist ja nicht so, dass die Demokraten jetzt mit Julian Assange kein Beef gehabt hätten.
Sind ja die Betroffenen, die Obama äh die die Obama ähm Präsidentschaft war ja die Betroffene,
da war der beiden Vize. Also ich glaube ähm da müsste der Biden jetzt echt sehr altersmilde geworden sein.
Dass der da jetzt nicht die die Rachgelüste auslebt.
Na ja klar, ich meine, die Diskussion wird natürlich jetzt von den äh Leuten, die Julia Assange unterstützen, entsprechend geführt mit der Argumentation, dass wir sozusagen das Ende der Pressefreiheit in USA.
Ahnung, inwiefern das in der aktuellen Debatte äh verfängt,
natürlich hm erwarten Sie sich gegebenenfalls ja auch noch Aufklärung über seine Verbindung zu Trump und äh diesen ganzen Wahlkampfsachen. Von daher,
na ja, kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass das jetzt demnächst auch stattfinden wird, das von der aktuellen britischen Regierung da kein großer Widerstand zu erwarten war. Ich glaube, das war von vorneherein klar.
Insbesondere nicht mit äh,
äh Rolle, weil die ist einfach eh total neben der Spur die Frau und äh ja da war nicht viel Hilfe zu erwarten.
Sie haben jetzt äh eine Berufung angekündigt. Dafür haben sie eine zwei Wochen Frist. Jetzt geht's aber ehrlich gesagt davon aus, dass sie also jetzt nicht in den zwei Wochen die Arbeit erledigen müssen, weil sie ja wahrscheinlich einfach schon vorher erledigt haben,
Aber ja, die werden sich äh hm,
werden jetzt mit Sicherheit, es war ja auch ganz klar nochmal äh vor den High Cord gehen und dann in Berufung gehen und dann bliebe ihnen auch noch der äh Europäische Gerichtshof. Äh das heißt äh,
14 Tage ab dem Beschluss, der war am 16. oder 176. das heißt bis grob Ende des Monats haben sie,
Zeit in Berufung zu gehen, das werden sie auf jeden Fall machen und an den High Cord, dann weiß ich nicht, was da passiert,
oder wie lange da der äh Prozess ist,
Und dann würden sie potenziell auch noch gegen den EuGH gehen, wobei ich nicht genau weiß, also den Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte.
Nicht in ist eine Institution der EU. Ich weiß europäische Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Das ist wieder.
Organ der Europäischen Union.
Des Europarats. Da gehört nämlich dann auch noch Großbritannien dazu. Also das ist sozusagen da äh.
Die Menschenrechtskonhition der äh die europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention ist die Grundlage und die hat Großbritannien unterzeichnet. Deswegen kann man da noch.
Genau und irgendwie so ein bisschen hören sie sogar noch auf die, auch wenn's ja schon seit längerem da auch in Großbritannien äh Kampagnen dagegen gibt, da auch noch auszutreten, weil Menschenrechte und so weiter, das ist ja äh,
verhindert ja alles, äh dass dass das UK wieder great again wird. Ähm allerdings gab's ja vor kurzem grad noch ein Urteil vom ähm
IGMR, die ja dann diese andere Praxis gestoppt haben, das ist dann halt auch äh auf Pretty Pelz misst gewachsen. Ich weiß noch was mitbekommen hast. Diese Nummer mit irgendwie dem Abschieben von von äh Flüchtenden,
mit einem Deal nach Ruanda? Also Leute, die Asyl suchen in Großbritannien schicken sie dann nach Ruanda,
dann geprüft, ob ihr Asyl irgendwie äh gerechtfertigt ist und wenn, dann dürfen sie in bleiben.
Dass er nett. Haben sie eine.
Es ist alles so schmutzig und furchtbar, was da gerade passiert. Man kann sich für dieses Land nur schämen.
Na ja.
Das ist äh wirklich ein bisschen peinlich.
Also wie gesagt, also von Großbritannien ist da nicht viel Hilfe zu erwarten, sondern wenn überhaupt, dann äh können jetzt hier IGMA, R oder vielleicht eben noch die USA selber, wovon ich nicht ausgehe, was äh bewegen, aber ich glaube, wir müssen es langsam ein bisschen darauf einstellen,
dass dieser Tag kommen wird.
Mhm. Ja, also,
absoluter Irrsinn, ne. Ich habe da auch also grob zu getwittert. Der hat das immer gesagt, der Assanches von schon 2010 hat der gesagt, die USA wollen,
mich haben und mich in Knast bringen. Da haben alle gesagt, so Quatsch, dieser Kappes, der hat ja immer gesagt, es gibt ein. Das haben die fertig in der Schublade, das holen die in dem Moment raus, wo sie mich kriegen. Unsinn.
Kaum ist Trump Präsident, holte das Ding aus der Tasche. Sagt er, guck mal hier,
1.000 Seiten äh haben wir eine Schublade gefunden, wollen wir jetzt mal sehen. Und ähm dann natürlich hat der auch immer gesagt, die Briten wollen mich ausliefern, deswegen hat er ja sieben Jahre,
oder was in der in der äh Botschaft Ecuadors da rumgehangen, bis sie ihn rausgezerrt haben.
Auch immer alle gesagt, die Briten, die liefern dich doch nicht aus. Ach Quatsch! Hör mal, die ja, die verhaften dich jetzt, weil du da äh gegen deine Bel-Auflagen verstoßen hast und in die Botschaft gegangen bist. Da musst du jetzt ins Gefängnis.
Dann hat er da ja auch wieder ein Jahr gehangen für den Verstoß gegen die Bay of Flagge. Dann hätte er eigentlich gegen guck mal hier,
Auslieferungsversuch an die USA, die dich 175 Jahre in den Knast tun wollen. Exakt das, was der seit seit weit über zehn Jahren die ganze Zeit gesagt hat und alle immer so, ja, du bist doch bekloppt, du bist doch bekloppt. Und jetzt,
Wo es soweit ist, sagen sie, oh ja, kannste machen nix. Das ist schon wirklich enttäuschend und ähm,
kein Artikel kann diesen Menschen unterstützen ohne sich vorher weiträumig von dem Typen zu distanzieren,
Selbst die stärksten Unterstützer,
oder sonst, die müssen dann immer sagen, ja schwieriger Typ und so und politisch kann man ja sagen, was man will, aber man muss ja dann doch mal anerkennen, es geht hier um Journalismus und das ist ähm,
schon faszinierend, dass sie das geschafft haben,
dermaßen inakzeptabel zu machen, dass,
der und er vielleicht auch seinen Teil dazu beigetragen hat.
Definitiv.
Aber aber, dass der der wirkliche Ischu, um den es hier geht, nämlich dass der wegen Inanspruchnahme fundamentaler wichtiger Rechte für jede Demokratie,
und alle so ein bisschen daneben stehen und mit den Füßen scharren. Ja, weil er irgendwie ein Arschloch ist. Und das ist schwierig. Das ist eben eine Abstraktion,
die ich, wo ich auch weiß, dass sie schwierig ist und ihm vielleicht einige Leute auch nicht leisten können.
Grundrechte gelten auch für Arschlöcher.
Bessere Problem. Nein, das ist äh nee, Entschuldigung.
Manchmal ist das auch ein Problem, aber ein Problem, mit dem man leben muss.
So, Deutschland hat sich jetzt relativ klar gegen die Chatkontrolle positioniert. Ähm ähm.
Du bei Lance warst und da Einfluss genommen hast.
In der in der Sendung wurde Nancy Phaser dazu gefragt, hat auch sehr klar gesagt, dass sie dagegen ist. Das hat ihr ja dann auch den den Täterschutzvorwurf von ähm.
Äh eingebrockt, ja.
Von uns zu äh äh eingebrockt, ja und ähm sie hat aber in der Sendung eine, sagen wir mal, noch nicht ganz spezifische Auskunft äh oder Ankündigung gemacht,
ähm dass sie also ich ich zitiere jetzt mal, was sie gesagt hat, so sie an die IP-Adressen ran,
Es war jetzt in der Sendung, sage ich mal, noch nicht der der abschließende Plan,
spezifiziert, ob das jetzt ein bedeutet,
welches sich auch übrigens im äh Koalitionsvertrag findet oder,
Ob das eine Ausweitung der Speicherfristen für Bestandsdatenauskünfte betrifft.
Mhm.
In den meisten Fällen in Deutschland ist es so, du hast.
Bestandsdaten, das ist ein Mensch hat einen Anschluss, der zahlt eine Rechnung, der ähm der ist irgendwie registriert auf ähm der ist registriert auf diese Person, die muss eine Rechnung zahlen,
Das ist quasi die Bestandsdaten. So, dann gibt es Verkehrsdaten, Verkehrsdaten bedeutet,
Alles, was jetzt da die erbrachte Dienstleistung betrifft und ein Thema, was hier immer alle beschäftigt ist, ob nun die IP-Adresse,
zu den Verkehrsdaten gehört oder zu den Bestandsdaten,
Thema ist dahingehend geklärt, dass äh aktuell die meisten Provider um die sieben Tage festhalten,
welcher welcher IP-Adresse, zu welchem Zeitpunkt, welcher Kundin zugeordnet war.
Das reicht exakt aus für diejenigen, die den Prozess automatisiert und es äh und perfektioniert haben,
eine solche Auskunft zu verlangen, nämlich diejenigen, die Abmahnungen verschenken. Diese sieben Tage reichen genau für diejenigen, die jetzt schnell hinkriegen,
die diesen Prozess in Deutschland optimiert haben und industrialisiert haben, nämlich die,
Abmahnungsindustrie, ja? Die schafft es genau zack in den rein, IP-Adresse innerhalb von 7 Tagen
die Bestandsdatenauskunft verlangen,
Anschlussinhaberen und Anschlussinhaberinnen dann äh drei Monate später einen Brief schicken.
Und sie äh erpressen. Ja, mit äh viel zu hohen Forderungen,
der Aussicht vor Gericht zu verlieren. Die kriegen das hin, so,
Könnte es sein, dass die Innenministerin darauf hinarbeitet, dass die Speicherfristen erhöht werden, die das wie lange das noch möglich ist? Zum Beispiel könntet ihr sagen, die Mindestspeicherfrist ist jetzt nicht mehr,
äh sieben Tage oder sonst was, sondern wir wollen das einen Monat haben, dass wir nämlich eine IP-Adresse einen Monat lang noch auflösen können. Ich könnte aber auch sagen, sechs Monate,
Wenn Sie sich dazu entscheiden sollte, haben wir natürlich eine ganze Reihe Begehrlichkeiten, die sich danach richten werden, entsprechend müsste ein solcher Vorstoß mit sehr vielen Safe-Guards Richterinnen Vorbehalt und sonstigen ausgestattet werden.
De facto wäre das aber so etwas wie,
Ja, also nahe an einer Personalausweis oder Kennzeichenpflicht im Internet. Das könnte man eigentlich sagen, ja? Das Kennzeichen ist auch immer zu dir auflösbar und wenn du dich ohne ein Kennzeichen nicht mehr im Internet bewegen kannst, dann wäre das hier der Fall,
Quickfree wiederum, heißt, es gibt keine, es gibt ähm eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
die für alle gilt, für sagen wir mal einen Tag und das ist im Prinzip wie so ein überlaufender Cash. Also es gibt eine einen Tag Vorratsdatenspeicherung für alle oder von mir aus auch sieben Tage oder drei Tage.
Dann sind die Daten aber weg. Also da kommt jeden Tag der neue Tag rein und einer nach der Frist fällt raus.
Und diese Daten darf aber niemand zugreifen, nur mit Richterinnenbeschluss, vor Exampel,
Dann kriegst du die letzten drei Tage und eine in die Zukunft gerichtete Vollspeicherung von allem. Das wäre die Möglichkeit oder diese Konstruktion soll umgehen,
Verdachtlose und oder die Verdachtsunabhängige Vorratsspeicherung für alle, sondern eben nur die Anlassbezogene und das heißt eben das, was was für alle gespeichert wird, da kommst du nur mit Richterbeschluss dran,
und das, was dann in die Zukunft gespeichert wird, ist eine zielgerichtete Maßnahme auf eine Person.
Auch nicht geil, auch hier müssen natürlich die entsprechenden Safe Guards rein, die Richterin vorbehalten, nur bei schwerer Kriminalität und sonstigen. Das sind die, die beim nächsten Mal, wenn die CDU wieder an der Macht ist, ähm abgebaut werden. Wir kennen das Spiel,
So jetzt war aber der Frau leider in dieser Sendung noch nicht der der ein fester ein festes Konzept zu,
entnehmen, in welche Richtung sie denn steuern wird. Eventuell hat sie es nicht, weil sie auch in der Sendung angekündigt hat, dass sie nochmal mit der auf deren Mist ja diese Chatkontrolle-Geschichte gewachsen ist, sprechen möchte. Das hat sie auch glaube ich getan am nächsten Tag,
Mal gucken, wie das gelaufen ist, dass sie da jetzt irgendwie etwas erarbeiten. Was ihnen zu wünschen wäre,
Sie aufhören, mit irgendwelchen Lobbyistinnen und Lobbyisten zu reden, wie zum Beispiel diesem, der da rumgerannt ist in Brüssel,
sondern zum Beispiel mal mit.
Dem Bund Bund der Kriminalbeamten, den ich ja in der Regel als ähm relativ zielorientiert kennengelernt habe, auch in Podiumsdiskussionen,
auch in ministeriumsnahen Podiumsdiskussionen, die nämlich auch klar sagen, ey Vorratszeiten sprechen, hört uns auf. Wir haben genug Daten,
Wir brauchen ist, ist zielgerichtetere Maßnahmen und ähm sie sicherlich auch in dieser Chatkontrolle und den ähm und der Datenmenge sicherlich keine Erleichterung ihrer Arbeit sehen würden.
Also Deutschland positioniert sich sehr belastbar äh gegen die Chatkontrolle mit kritischen Fragen an die EU-Kommission mit ähm,
klaren Bekenntnissen der relevanten äh Regierungsvertreterinnen und Bundestags äh Mitglieder in der äh in den Bundestagsdiskussionen mit klarer Absage der Innenministerin,
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob die halten und ob die das international auch entsprechend durchsetzen.
Ne und ob da nicht noch eine Richtlinienkompetenz des Bundeskanzlers kommt.
Hast du gesehen, hat irgendeiner ins Kanzleramt geschrieben? Wo ist Olaf? Großes großes Theater. Großes Thema, da war.
Bestimmt gleich wieder Hausdurchsuchung, oder?
Im ganzen Amt. Wo ist der.
Polohemd in einem neuen Euro.
Ich sehe schon die Abreißzettel, die alle Laternen, Bundeskanzler halt laufen.
So dann haben wir dann haben wir äh einen einen italienischen Staatstrojaner,
aus aus italienischer Produktion,
der jetzt von äh mehreren ähm analysiert wurde. Ich glaube einmal von Lookout und einmal von ähm Google, einem Google Fred Analysis Group.
Übrigens super, ne? Das Staatstrainer Analyse ein immer größeres Hobby von immer professionelleren Gruppen wird,
Ich beanspruche ja nach wie vor die erste, mir Bekannte hat der äh CCC damals gemacht, mit ozapft ist,
Wir sind ja auch an dem Thema äh ein bisschen drangeblieben zumindest dann noch mit der Analyse, aber jetzt so mit Amnesty,
Citizen Lab und jetzt sogar hier Lookout und äh Google Fred äh äh Fred Analysis Group äh sind da jetzt äh glaube ich ganz ganz andere professionalisierte Kräfte dran, das ist auch sehr gut,
Immer sein Staatstrainer sich angeschaut, der in Kasachstan zum Einsatz kam und offenbar italienischer äh Genese ist. Ähm,
Was sich an dem Ding spannend fand, ist, wie die den wie die den auf die auf die ähm Systeme bekommen haben,
Die haben den Leuten ähm eine eine App angedreht und zwar, weil sie den äh indem sie ihn den den.
Internet abgedreht haben und dann gesagt haben, lad dir mal diese App runter, dann geht's wieder. Also jetzt nicht besonders elegant, aber einmal kannst du es auf jeden Fall machen,
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, in Deutschland gibt's ja auch den gesetzlichen Stand jetzt seit kurzem
das TK-Anbieter umleiten müssen, die sind zur Umleitung verpflichtet, um bei der Anbringung von Quellen-TKÜ-Maßnahmen ähm Beihilfe zu leisten.
Umleitung von äh.
Netzwerkverbindung.
Also beispielsweise, du machst ihr du hast irgendeine alte Software, die ein Update über HTTP macht, dann leitest du um und schickst stattdessen halt ein Softwareupdate mit dem Staatstrainer.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, da habe ich mich ja immer gewundert, wie wie willst du das denn ähm,
Wie willst du das hinkriegen, ne? Funktioniert das,
was damals noch aus der Debatte rauskam war, was ja auch diskutiert wurde, die Telemediendienst, also im Prinzip die Pflicht, dass Google und Apple helfen.
Das haben wir zum Glück noch rausgekriegt, weil das die Telekommunikationsanbieter das machen müssen, ist, sage ich mal, das kleinere,
kleinere Problem, weil wir eben zum Glück dank Edward Snowden seit 2013 relativ viel,
eben über HTTPS machen. Da kommt aber natürlich jetzt eventuell die Musik demnächst
EU-Kommission sagt, jeder Browser, der hier in unserem Markt vertrieben werden soll, soll, muss auch noch mal irgendwie EU-CA drin haben oder so. Also das Ding ist noch nicht zu Ende gekämpft, aber ich fand auf jeden Fall mal diesen Infektionsweg ganz lustig. Also wenn ihr in Kasachstan auf einmal kein Netz mehr habt und eine SMS kommt, nachdem wir die App runter.
Macht's besser nicht.
Ich gebe denen zumindest mal einen Punkt, hat offenbar geklappt, der der Angriffspfad und den Leuten das Internet wegzunehmen äh bringt die äh in eine Situation, wo sie viel machen,
Ihnen verspricht, dass es wieder Internet gibt und wenig darüber nachdenken. Also es ist eigentlich ein valider äh eleganter Phishing-Angriff.
Also sieht so aus, technisch sportlichen Aspekten äh herausbewertet.
Sportlichen Aspekten, ja. Der Piratenpartei wurde Server weggenommen. Hast du mitbekommen.
Tatsächlich nicht warum denn eigentlich?
Die haben,
Also die hatten offenbar einen Server. Auf diesem Server waren neben ihrer Haupt-Pirat-Parteiseite oder was ähm auch so ein also ein ein Ketsipritt.
Also verschlüsselter Online-Editor, den man geschert nutzen kann.
Du hast so einen du hast einen Online Editor und du hast eine eine so eine URL,
Der Teil vor dem also der Key für die Verschlüsselung ist quasi so ein Anker in Hash, der mit dran ist,
Der Clou ist, das habe ich hier für ein anderes System auch schon mal benutzt. Der Clou ist, der NK wird nicht mit übertragen an den Server. Und wenn du den Key im in diesem Hashtag hast,
Kannst du den Leuten Link geben die kriegen,
Auf den URL zu, dann nimmt ein Javascript, nimmt sich das, was hinter dem ist, nutzt diesen Key zum Entschlüsseln der Inhalte,
Aber trotzdem, was du dir da jetzt reinklimperst, wird verschlüsselt in diesem Pad gespeichert. Das heißt, der Server hat keine Daten.
Nur im Browser läuft und der Browser braucht nur diesen Key und den kriegt ihr quasi lokal und das äh bleibt da nicht drin. Es kann natürlich dann noch in der Browser-Historie irgendwie der Key hängen bleiben und solche Geschichten, aber zumindest ist das Ding server-seitig erstmals.
Genau, es ist ein genau und das ist natürlich auch genau die Idee, dass du auf dem Server, der eben diese Daten nicht hast, dass die trotzdem öffentlich sind, in dem Moment, wo jemand den Link teilt, ist eine Sache, aber du kannst quasi auf serverseitig nicht irgendwas machen.
Ja äh da haben jetzt irgendwelche Leute einen äh irgendeinen Polizeilieg über G7-Daten gemacht und dann hat die äh Staatsanwaltsanwaltschaft München,
Der Piratenpartei Deutschland den den Server weggenommen. Teilweise auch ähm Mitgliederdaten,
Und äh ja, die da eben auch drauf waren, ich bin mir jetzt so ein bisschen äh unsicher, wie viele Daten unterschiedlicher Provenienz man auf einem Server haben sollte.
Ob das jetzt so äh datenhygienisch ist? Ich meine, vielleicht hat man's auch drauf ankommen lassen,
dann sozusagen Skandal äh fest zu sein. Aber äh an sich ist das keine keine gute Idee, solche Systeme zu mixen.
Die veröffentlichen Daten waren eben äh teilweise äh Verschlusssache NFD detaillierter Einblick in Polizeistrategie, ja okay, eine Münchener Polizeistrategie ist relativ einfach.
Sieht aus wie ein Türke,
Hatten hat ein Kletterseil dabei und will in Urlaub fahren. Glauben an dich, der ist bestimmt von Greenpeace. Also die nehmen einfach, also Münchener Polizeistrategie zum G7? Würde ich sagen Bürgerstrategie zum G7 ist Bayern meiden.
Was halten die dann da reingeschrieben? G sieben, du bist so eins Pimmel?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Gleich beschlagbar, alles Hausdurchsuchung, volles Programm.
Aber es zeigt natürlich auch mal wieder hier diesen absoluten Irrsinn von diesem ganzen G7-Kram jetzt deiner politischen Partei den Server aus dem Regal zu ziehen, ne. Also es ist natürlich wieder ein völlig übertriebenes
Sicherheitsding immerhin waren sie diesmal so so schlau den Scheiß nicht in Hamburg zu machen und äh und da irgendwie die Leute fertig zu machen.
Sind gleich in die Berge gegangen.
Direkt in die Berge gegangen.
Ill mau. Ist das schöner? Was nochmal?
Nee und da kommt man jetzt gerade auch echt schwer hin. Ich habe das mit einem 9-Euro-Ticket versucht.
Ich dachte, du machst die ganze Zeit in Sylt. Du bist von Sylt.
Ich nehme ein paar Punks von Sylt und setzte ihn an den Dorfbrunnen, aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Tja.
Als.
Oh das hatte wirklich Dimension, diese Meldung, nicht? Also was ist passiert? Giffey äh hatte einen äh Online-Videocall mit ähm,
Dem Bürgermeister von Kiew und wollte mit ihm Dinge besprechen und stellt sich irgendwie raus,
Äh also es stellte sich dann.
Wladimir Klitschko.
Vitali. Vladimir ist sein Bruder, der ist aber nicht der Bürgermeister. Das ist übrigens das Lustige, dem Spiegel kam dann aus,
ganz heimischer äh Kommentar. Ja, ja, ja, äh hier ein Foto äh muss man doch auseinander halten können. Haben das aber seinen Bruder genommen,
Also auch so richtig schön. Richtig schön in den in den Archeimer gegriffen und.
Die ganze Nummer ist irgendwie total crazy. Also immer sie ist auch nicht die einzige. Es war glaube ich auch noch der Bürgermeister in Wien und vielleicht gab's auch noch ein paar andere Opfer, die äh ähnliches Ding hatten und dann kam halt so die Meldung, na ja,
Hier äh deep fake und da jetzt würde hier mit richtig heißer Computertechnologie wurde hier der Klitschko da in den Chat gerändert und so weiter und äh alles ganz gefährlich, ne?
Das ist ja schon seit längerem so eine,
So eine Drohung, die so im Raum steht, wenn man sich mal so die akademischen Ergebnisse in diesem Forschungsbereich anschaut, das ist schon äh ziemlich bemerkenswert, ne? Also man kann ja heutzutage sowohl die Stimme als auch die,
Optik äh auf Basis von existierenden Videoaufnahmen oder Fotoaufnahmen,
sehr gut nachbilden, das heißt, es gibt so tatsächlich Systeme, wo du dann irgendwie äh selber reinsprechen kannst, selber vor der Kamera stehst, dann wird deine,
Bild äh analysiert in Echtzeit, deine ganzen Kopfbewegungen, Gesichtsausdrücke et cetera PP und das, was du sagst und dann wird es halt sowohl akustisch auf die Stimmgegebenheiten der Zielperson,
Typischerweise mal Obama,
und ähm auf einmal hast du da so einen redenden Obama, der irgendwie genau das sagt, äh was du machst und genau dieselben Bewegungen äh mit dem Bund macht und mit dem ganzen Kopf,
du in dem Moment machst. Problem ist nur, da sind halt.
In Echtzeit ist das aber schon ein bisschen sehr aufwendig, ne?
Ist der eine Aspekt und der andere Aspekt ist,
das das eben auch, sagen wir mal, das Ausgangsmaterial, also beiderlei Ausgangsmaterial, muss auch schon so in einer gewissen Qualität und Reinheit vorliegen, ne, Hintergründe et cetera. Und da gab's dann halt auch gleich jemanden, Journalisten, der sich
das mal genauer angeschaut hat und festgestellt hat, also für so ein deep fake ist das ja mal überhaupt nicht das richtige Material.
So komplizierte Wappengeschichten im Hintergrund, so mit Überlagerung und es stellte sich letztlich raus
Das Ganze ist halt sind halt Videoaufnahmen von einem älteren Interview, was äh Vitali Klitschko gegeben hat und offensichtlich ist dies nur,
quasi so vorbereitet worden. Also man hat das äh geschnitten und dann mehr oder weniger fertige ähm Passagen,
gespielt. Den Eindruck macht es zumindest.
Also was der Daniel Laufer hat sich das ja angeschaut. Es gab also mehrere Fotos als Beweis, so hier wurden wir gedeepfakt,
Und der Daniel Laufer hat quasi das Originalvideo gefunden, aus dem die Sequenzen sind,
Dann hat er festgestellt, diese Sequenzen, also was da zu sehen ist in dem Foto von,
Wird gedeepfaked? Entspricht 100Prozent dem Videoframe aus der Sequenz, die offenbar Vorlage war,
Wenn das jetzt gedeept faked wäre, würdest du nicht eine pixelgenaue Abbildung des exakt gleichen Frames erwarten, sondern du würdest irgendwelche Verzerrungen sehen, aber nicht exakt den gleichen Frame,
Was die hier offenbar gemacht haben ist doch einfach nur die haben einfach irgendein irgendwas abgespielt, wo der halt irgendwas sagt und haben dann,
Die Übersetzerin sagen lassen. Der hat übrigens gerade gesagt äh ihr seid ihr seid doof und ihr müsst jetzt alle ukrainischen Geflüchteten äh melden, die sich dem Wehrdienst entziehen.
Also schon sagen wir mal jetzt nicht wirklich so ein deep fake. Also das war jetzt eher da braucht das jetzt nicht so viel kürzliche Intelligenz, um,
Um die irgendwie also ich.
Hat sich ja dann auch selber noch in dem Video gemeldet, hat gesagt, Leute, ich kann Deutsch.
Ich rede ich rede doch nicht. Ich rede doch nicht mit einem Übersetzer mit euch. Englisch und Deutsch kann ich auch richtig gut.
Mich schon mal im Fernsehen gesehen.
Viele Grüße.
Alter, das stimmt dir nicht. Das ist ja wirklich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja äh der Typ, der war jahrelang in Deutschland war hier ein Superstar. Ich meine, dass Deutschland ist das Land, was sie groß gemacht hat so, der war hier superpopulär.
Oder oder wo sie groß geworden sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob Deutschland die groß gemacht hat, aber die deutschen.
Sein sein seine Boxkarriere hat sich vor allem halt aus Deutschland heraus. Ich meine der ist ein internationaler äh Superstar äh des Boxens gewesen.
Er hatte deutsche Boxstelle oder wie das dann heißt. Boxenstall? Nee, Boxgym.
Sie waren in Deutschland basiert und und sie konnten Deutsch und sie waren und sie waren ja hier auch lokale Superstars. Ich meine, sie gehören ja zu diesen wenigen äh.
Ukraine? Nein, sorry.
Könnte jetzt gar nicht alle Ukrainer aufzählen, die hier.
Stars geworden sind.
Also da sind sie bestimmt die Nummer 1 und die Nummer zwei, also.
Und Nummer drei.
Äh ja würde mir jetzt erstmal keiner einfallen, deswegen setze ich die erst mal an, die ersten beiden Plätze
Wobei ich mir nicht unbedingt so sicher bin, dass jeder äh automatisch die Ukraine so im Kopf hatte, sondern man muss halt einfach nur so äh offensichtlich kommt ihr erst mal nicht aus Deutschland. Aber sie haben halt mit ihrem Witz und mit ihrer Art und Weise ähm,
eigentlich auch immer immer eine gute Figur gemacht. Also sie waren halt auch im Entertainment äh sehr gut, aber sie waren halt auch nie so phonifaky.
Habe ich auch immer sehr gemocht. Also ich hatte schon immer eine große Sympathie für die Klitschkos, weil die waren halt irgendwie real. So also die waren halt.
Ja also die haben auch sehr real agiert.
Ja da also vor allem in diesem Boxbusiness, wo ja wirklich die meisten wirklich auch einer an der Waffel haben, weil sie wahrscheinlich irgendwann auch mal einen an die Waffel bekommen haben.
Da sind ja größtenteils von verschont geblieben.
Die haben sie konnten das ganz gut abwehren, das hat sicherlich auch geholfen, aber sie waren schon auch auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise immer sehr äh zugänglich und sehr straight und ähm,
Ja, dann ist er ja in die Ukraine gegangen vor vielen Jahren, als es äh hieß, wir müssten dieses Land jetzt endlich mal von der Korruption befreien und dann hat er sich als Bürgermeister aufgestellt, seitdem ist er,
Bürgermeister von Kiew so der haben wohl auch erst im Rahmen,
des Krieges so richtig zueinander gefunden, aber sind definitiv jetzt die bekanntesten Gesichter in Deutschland.
Also die äh bekanntere äh ukrainische Stars haben dann eher also keine äh keine äh Wurzeln ihrer Karriere in Deutschland, aber zum Beispiel Mila, Kunis und Milla,
Jovovic, die Mila, die kennt man, glaube ich. Ja, die äh Melakuie spielt bei Family Guy gerade mit,
F ich glaube die hat so Resident Evil und solche Sachen mitgemacht. Äh Natascha Jarovenko,
Ich gucke jetzt nur auf Gesichter, die ich kenne. Also wir haben auch noch einige ukrainische Weltstars im im Hollywood-Bereich.
Ja, aber alles kein Vergleich mit den.
Nein, die sind das sind.
Die sind einfach eine eigene Marke in Deutschland gewesen und äh.
International. Ich meine, die haben ja auch international den Leuten auf die Fresse gehauen. Also es war ja nicht nur in Deutschland.
Nicht nur da, aber ist ja so, ist so ein bisschen so dieser Rudi Carrell-Effekt so, also manchmal hast du halt einfach Leute aus anderen Ländern, ja.
A, die dann ja.
Bill Ramsy und irgendwie also so so äh gibt ja verschiedene Personen, die äh einfach in Deutschland es gibt ja auch so Deutsche, die zum Beispiel es gibt so so einen Komiker, den hier
keiner kennt, der in Großbritannien quasi immer die erste Adresse ist, wenn's um Deutschland geht, der da irgendwie in allen Talkshows auftaucht. Ich habe seinen Namen schon wieder vergessen. Ich finde den auch nicht witzig.
Ist ja so echt. Ja, David, sehr gutes Beispiel
Also einfach so Leute frag mal die in den USA nach David Hesselhoff ja? Ich meine ist so der Ferder liefen aber hier einfach der totale äh äh Superstar geworden weil die einfach irgend so eine gewisse irgendwas getriggert haben in Deutschland,
Komisch. Ich meine, sowas hat wahrscheinlich jedes Land.
Zwei Männer, bumm bumm, das war für die Deutschen einfach auch eine ansprechende Unterhaltung.
Und man muss echt sagen, guck mal, ich habe mir hier gerade mal nebenbei auf Video äh auf äh YouTube angemacht, alle Knockouts von Vitali Klitsch,
ist relativ also ist ein ist ist ein relativ kurzes Video mit sehr viel,
13 Minuten immer so bumm bumm also die das war schon auch also die die Käffe habe ich auch geguckt äh wie die boah die Dilotte oben. Das ist wirklich ein bisschen tragisch.
Der war auch wirklich Mister äh Steel Hammer oder wie haben sie ihn genannt? Also.
Warte mal, Vitali ist der kleinere, ne? Ist der größere.
War der große Bruder und äh seiner Mutter versprochen, dass er auf seinen äh kleinen Bruder aufpasst.
Deswegen musste der dann erstmal oh das ist also das ist ja auch wirklich ich meine Knock-Out ist tragisch, ne.
Sehr lohnenswert, kann man kann man kann man sich mal so eine Doku anschauen, über die gibt's wirklich viel zu erzählen. Das ist äh wirklich äh eine krasse Combo, die beiden.
Also ein Knockout, ich also das ist halt eine Gehirnerschüttung, die Leute, die werden halt bewusstlos, weil die denen so dermaßen auf die Runkel hauen, ne.
Ja. Es ist Boxen, mein Freund.
Die Fallen, die fallen halt einfach hin, weil die bewusstlos.
Jupps, da ist dann äh dann macht's kurz Blitz und das war's.
Scheiße, können wir gar nicht angucken. Okay, ja.
Okay, ja. Ja.
Ich bin dafür, dass der mal äh.
Also er ist auf jeden Fall sehr real und er kann Deutsch und das sollten sich jetzt die Bürgermeister in Europa vielleicht mal merken. Also wenn der anruft und da ist ein Übersetzer, dann ist er wahrscheinlich was falsch.
Dann haben wir noch zwei Kurzmeldungen, die wir jetzt äh unter dem Zeitdruck äh etwas kürzer fassen und zwar,
Es gibt gerade einen Skandal, um das Ulmer Verschwörhaus. In Ulm gibt es eine ähm seit einiger Zeit das ein cooler,
Hacker und Maker Space?
In dem übrigens auch äh BliepTrack natürlich ein bisschen verbunden ist, die vielen von euch vielleicht bekannt ist von den äh C3s, die hat das äh Design für den 36 Zit drei gemacht,
Also den letzten Kongress der der noch äh der stattgefunden hat aktuell ähm und.
Vorher auch mal diese animierten Design-Konzep.
Animierte die generatives Design war auch schon mal äh,
ähm gut ist aber jetzt glaube ich nur eine der bekannteren äh Verschwörhausvertreterinnen. So äh,
Jetzt haben die da in Ulm dieses dieses Verschwörhaus gebaut. Wunderschön, alles cool,
und hm dann hat die Stadt Ulm gesagt, okay wir lassen uns aber den Namen Verschwörhaus bei Marken und Patentamt anmelden, wenn man als Marke eintragen für die Stadt Ulm,
Ist ja supergeil. Wir haben das hier auch so ein bisschen unterstützt dieses Projekt und so, ne und ähm.
Jetzt sind die sich aber jetzt sagt die Stadt Ulm, wir können das ja vielleicht ohne euch weiterführen,
Diesen Raum, dann sucht ihr euch einfach was anderes, weil wir haben ja ein bisschen andere äh Regeln und quasi die Zusammenarbeit zwischen ähm dem Verein, der das Verschwörhaus betreibt und der Stadt Ulm,
Ist äh quasi eskaliert, weil äh der Name Verschwörhaus war eben laut der Ehrenamtlichen, die es aufgebaut hat, nicht die Idee der Stadt,
Sie mussten den Namen sogar gegen Widerstände durch,
setzen, was man sich auch vorstellen kann, dass eine Stadt nicht sagt, geil, wir wollen Verschwörhaus haben. Dann haben Sie's aber ähm,
hat die Stadt das eben als Marke registriert und äh die die dürften aber jetzt gerne kostenlos weiter die Marke dieser Stadt für ihr Verschwörhaus nutzen.
Haben die Widerspruch beim Markenamt eingelegt und haben gesagt, ey Leute,
Ding haben wir so benannt, das ist überhaupt nicht euers und dann hat die Stadt Ulm gesagt, na ja, wenn ihr hier weiter euren Mietvertrag haben wollt und wenn ihr hier weiter rein wollt, dann müsst ihr diesen Widerspruch zurücknehmen.
Das heißt, die die Stadt hat jetzt einen Streit mit dem Hacker Space,
diese Stadt bereichert, mit dem sie sich schmücken, angefangen um die Namensrechte. Und ich sage jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, dass die Stadt sich den Namen ausgedacht hat, das besteht doch den Lachtest nicht.
Das ist auch, sagen wir mal, wirklich eine sehr unkluge Idee.
Sehr unklug.
Also das ist einfach so eine Art Community, um mal so einen kleinen Tipp zu geben,
eine Kreativität an den Tag legen kann, mit der will man sich eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt so beschäftigen. Da ähm das könnte einfach das könnte einfach unangenehm werden.
Die Sorge ist ja vor allem auch, dass die ähm also ich kann verstehen. Also es gibt einen Punkt. Die Stadt Ulm will natürlich jetzt nicht mit dem Verschwörhaus schmücken,
Die hat natürlich Sorge, dass die eigentlichen Verschwörungsgründerinnen sich in zehn Jahren vom Acker machen,
mit ihrer Förderung durchhauen. So zum Beispiel so Finnstyle oder äh Patrick Hennigstyle von äh von der Luca-App. Ja, sie kann schon verstehen, dass man potentiell da Risiken sieht.
Aber dann sollen sie das Ding halt sollen sie sich halt einen anderen Namen für ihr geiles Haus äh finden und sagen, das Verschwörhaus ist halt ein ein Teil davon oder so,
Ja, also da gibt es eine ähm einen offenen Brief, den wir verlinkt haben,
Wo auch äh der CCC sich angeschlossen hat und viele andere und äh ich denke, da muss man jetzt auch klare Kante zeigen,
Weil äh das also es ist einfach,
Faszinierend, ich habe vor längerer Zeit äh schon vor ein paar Monaten mit da mal persönlich drüber gesprochen, was das auch weißt du, wie die denn da fertig gemacht werden. Da hast du endlich mal was in fucking Ulm,
und dann terrorisierst du die Leute, statt dich statt dich zu freuen, ja oder nimmst den nimmst eine Marke für die an,
Also da muss wirklich mal jemand hin und nachdenken.
So und dann haben wir äh hat die äh die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte einen Erfolg vom Bundesverfassungsgericht,
erlangt und zwar geht es dabei um den Datenstraftatbestand der Datenhederei, der Paragraph, der sehr erstaunlich äh war im im Sinne von,
Wer widerrechtlich erlangte Daten,
hat und an andere weitergibt. Und das war eine sehr komische ähm eine sehr komische Konstruktion, die spezifisch auf den Punkt,
getroffen hätte, dass ein Journalist die hat also,
Der Tim heckt was als alter enormes Aktivist? Gibt das ähm dem André Meister und dem Markus Beckededal bei Netzpolitik org,
Übrigens auch zu den äh Beschwerdeführern gehören.
Und dann sitzen Andre und Markus da und sagen, welchen Hacker könnten wir denn jetzt mal oder welche Person könnten wir finden, um diese Daten zu prüfen?
Ne, uns die war Wirklichkeit oder sonst was, ob's ob der Tim wirklich jetzt hier Bitcoin Schwachsteller hat oder so was, ja? Dann könnten die das aber nicht weitergeben,
Weil sie dann unter diesen Datenparagraphen fielen
Und hier wurde jetzt ähm eine Verfassungsbeschwerde eben, wie gesagt, Beschwerde für unter anderem Markus Andre, Peter Hornung vom NDR und Heil Seppel von der ARD und der hat jetzt das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt,
ähm,
Sie wurde formal nicht zur Entscheidung angenommen, aber äh die äh dadurch wurde halt klargestellt, durch dieses wir nehmen es nicht an, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht eben gesagt hat, hier ähm,
Äh äh es drängt sich auf, dass ein umfassender Ausschuss journalistischer Tätigkeit bezweckt wird, weil äh der,
Schutz der Pressefreiheit eben sowieso höher ist und auch wenn es da jetzt nicht spezifisch drin steht, ist völlig klar, dass das am Ende ähm,
sich klärt. Ja, also sie haben quasi in ihrer Ablehnung,
Gesagt, pass auf, sollte das jemals bei uns landen, ist eh klar, dass Journalistinnen und Journalisten davon ausgenommen.
Feiert die GFF als Erfolg, aber klar, die muss ja auch Erfolge feiern um Spenden zu bekommen,
Na, da ist ja einer. Es ist ja eine also es ist ja eine juristische Klärung,
haben sich diese Arbeit gemacht, die Verfassungsbeschwerde äh zu formulieren und ja zwanzig sieb1, jetzt ist es zwanzig zweiundzwanzig, fünf Jahre äh Rechtsunsicherheit,
haben damit jetzt äh hoffentlich erstmal ihr vorläufiges Ende gefunden,
So damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Ähm Termine können wir auch noch nächste Woche ankündigen und äh ja freuen uns, wenn ihr uns auf der Fusion besucht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Livestream,
Ich glaube nicht. Aber in der Aufzeichnung werden wir, werden Sie nachher online stellen, auf jeden Fall.
Na wir werden vor allem eine Aufzeichnung online stellen.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob du ob du auf dem Acker schneller kriegst.
Muss ich mir die Haare schön machen, was?
Kannste nicht so auftreten wie jetzt Tim. Vor allem nicht, wenn Karl kommt. Und der hätte ja gerne auch mal die Haare schön,
Der hat einen der hat einen schönen Hoodie.
Ich stehe ja nicht so in Konkurrenz zu anderen. Ist mir ja schon immer egal gewesen. Ähm ja, das kriege ich schon irgendwie hin,
ist ja nur so 100.000 Leute Veranstaltungen um einen herum, da kriegt man auch nochmal einen Podcast geschnitten. Mir ist vor allem wichtig, dass ich das ordentlich aufgezeichnet bekomme und äh ob das klappen wird, das werdet ihr dann,
sehen nächste Woche, ja.
Ich habe mich auf jeden Fall strategisch in die Nähe eines äh Starlink, einer Starling-Schüssel gestellt.
Sehr schön. Ach so, ich wollte dir gerade meine anbieten, aber hast du schon.
Nehme ich gerne mit. Ja.
Ne? Ja, kannste machen. Hast du schon Netz.
Leere Batterien.
Das könnte natürlich auch.
Wie schwer ist die? Das ist das ganze Ding da.
Schwer ist sie nicht. 40 Watt, braucht sie.
40 Watt. 5 5 Volt oder was?
Nee. Brauchst du mehr Volt? Zwölf. Nee. Zweihundertdreißig. Oh. Oh.
Oh. Ist in echt? Die wollen doch mal einen Inwerter.
Ist nicht die Ukraine-Edition, die es äh Elon Musk rausgehauen hat. Die kannst du auch aus dem Zigarettenanzünder äh powern, aber die wird hier leider noch nicht verkauft.
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass das Ding hat doch garantiert nicht intern 230 Volt.
Natürlich nicht. Das ist Netzteil dran, aber es gibt jetzt keinen explizite.
Was kommt denn aus dem Netzteil.
Aus Lisa kommt POEL also musste 48 Volt liefern. Kannst du jetzt irgendwie einen du kannst.
OE muss da nicht, ist das nicht informiert auf 48 Volt? Ist es das, ja?
Na ja es ja also es ist so ein gewisser Range von ich glaube von irgendwie paar und dreißig bis irgendwie paarundfünfzig oder irgendwie so was.
Es gibt also es gibt auch POE mit 12 Volt, bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Das kann sein, da bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ich hab's nicht nachgemessen.
Ja ja gibt's auch mit zwölf. Also okay, aber ich wusste gar nicht.
Aber wenn also du kannst es gerne ausprobieren, aber wenn sie kaputt ist, musst du es zahlen.
Du mir erstmal meinen Inverter zurück. Camper unter sich. Salatschüssel.
So Leute.
Tu mir meine Salatschüssel zurück, bevor du meine äh äh Starlink äh Antenne kriegst. Mein Starling Fock.
Du darfst bei mir nochmal die Brotbackmaschine benutzen. Leute, wir müssen Schluss machen. Ich habe was anderes zu tun. Äh tschüss, bis bald. Wir hören uns nächste Woche. Bis bald.
Ciao ciao.